[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
experts are saying that this is already
the most exciting world championship
match that magnus carlsen has ever
played yanapon hachi he came close to a
major upset yesterday and today he's
gonna have the white pieces so welcome
everyone to day three in the feed at
world championship match
[Music]
[Music]
the champion and his uh challenger are
tied after two games in dubai but grand
master david howell how close did magnus
carlsen come to actually losing
yesterday actually objectively according
to computers he was very close he was
definitely closer to losing than he was
to winning but magnus carson he is
resilient he found some practical
chances and at some point he was out
playing yandere pontiac it was a really
roller coaster game both sides had their
chances and in the end the draw was a
fair result today is going to be game
three
in the same amount of days both games
have lasted for four to five hours will
they feel a little bit drained today you
think i think for sure they will be but
it was part of magnus carson's match
strategy to draw out the games
especially at the beginning just to test
his challenger's stamina and i think we
might well be in for that again today
because tomorrow's the rest day they can
spend all of their energy today and did
we also yesterday start to see the
psychological battle being played out
yeah i think it's going to increase as
the days goes on uh as they go on the
psychological battle yesterday we saw
yandere pony actually barely spend any
time at the board he's trying to get in
magnus carson's head maybe he's also
trying to keep himself relaxed so we'll
see that psychological warfare continue
today yep the world champion magnus
carlsen he had his first game with the
white pieces yesterday a game that gave
us many big moments
on the second day of the free day world
championship janupomniacci proved to be
a dangerous challenger to magnus carlson
look at this black knight it's an
intruder it's a bit of an octopus there
with all of its tentacles controlling
lots of squares in white's camp and
magnus needs to get rid of that knight
asap yeah this shows magnus is in the
mood to fight he wants to win
and he's not materialistic at all we
might well see magnus give up a rook
that white rook in the bottom corner now
look at this napoli actually reacts
instantly wow straight back to the board
move magnus now has a big dilemma to
face that rook in the corner is under
fire and that white dart square bishop
also attacked this one has reached
boiling point now the next couple of
moves might decide the fate of this game
war
this was not on my radar at all he's
just given up a pawn
for free
uh what is the idea behind that one he's
still got his pen in his hand he's
trying to figure out what the point is
just see the hand kind of yeah make that
draw offer oh there we go draw offer and
it is a draw at some point i blundered
uh when i allowed knight c5 because i
didn't intend to suck quite as much
material as i actually did yeah the
position was very very interesting it
was going going my way for for a bit but
i couldn't really find a plan and then
he certainly had chances as well
yeah guys it's another beautiful day in
chess paradise the weather's still nice
and warm
beautiful clear blue sky and i was lucky
enough to run into yuri poga and herself
the chess legend you are on your way to
commentate the game so i will just ask
you a couple of quick questions how are
you enjoying your stay so far
oh this is amazing it's this is my first
time that i'm commentating a world
championship match but this is something
very special so anybody who can have the
opportunity to come here definitely
something to come to the expo in dubai
yeah it is quite quite an experience do
you have some thoughts or impressions of
the game so far you would like to share
with us
well so far i think it's extremely
exciting because the kickoff game game
one was already very interesting when
magnus played the knight a5 move and
sacrificed upon for initiative
it was a very interesting very detailed
game with very small nuances in there so
it was interesting where magnus might
have take a little bit over but when it
was a little bit dangerous for napo it
was very clear that he was very much
standing there very clear he said okay i
just have to fix the position make bring
my maneuvering with the knight and then
he saved the game and it was just a
repetition of moves and yesterday's game
was something absolutely amazing i think
for game two in a world championship
match it was just ups and downs endless
ideas to talk about to analyze and i
think all of us when we were analyzing
with anish it was like really endless
interesting ideas there and there were
moments which was extremely hard for
young especially after the opening but
in the middle game it was very dangerous
for magnus and it was so interesting to
follow the players
how
their body language gave some
information also to us and to each other
but of course some things is not about
body language some things are really
what happens in the board you cannot
hide it magnus had to sacrifice material
in order to be stay in the game and uh
at the end it was pretty clear that
instead of little bit torturing more
young magnus decided with his queen move
queen g4 to go into direction to
simplification and it was a draw so
these two draws was magnificent
magnificent and uh
i'm very much looking for virtual games
three well thank you very much this is
judit pogo providing the expert
commentary that you can find on the deep
dive podcast
broadcast i'm sorry and i know you have
to go and commentate right now so i will
let you go thank you very much and guys
back to you
thanks so much
and judith both on the ground in dubai
but here in the studio we have some
excellent people to commentate on
today's game also ginger gm simon
williams who spent yesterday at the good
night was it fun
it was great yeah it's a bit of a bit of
a change being in here um i'll be honest
i quite enjoyed the good night yeah but
it's lovely to join you for the first
time in the studio uh obviously i've
been watching the the tour over the last
year and i'm here i'm now here so um
round three the day before the rest day
it's gonna be found fantastic game i
think and uh if one player wins they're
gonna have a great lead going into that
rest day so exciting yeah definitely and
of course at the good night yesterday
with a bunch of norwegian fans being in
oslo were they at some point getting a
little nervous on magnus's behalf
i think the beer probably helps
so um
it's uh yeah this is the good night
chess pub in oslo and um they had the
big screens over there so they're
watching the chest they're enjoying the
chess and
i think it was a real up and down game
so you could sort of feel with the vibe
of the pub because obviously everyone's
supporting agnes because he's norwegian
and he goes down there quite a lot and
magnus was doing very well people quite
excited but then obviously at one point
it seemed like he might well lose the
game and there was there was a little
bit of concern maybe some more pints
being pulled at the bar at that moment
and um but it was it was it was a
brilliant day so much fun yeah watching
the action there yeah great and
it was a thrilling game you're like how
did the twitter world react to the
action yesterday um everyone thought the
game was absolutely intense uh again
everyone was concerned for magnus but
again impressed by nepomiacci's
defensive skills and how resourceful he
was and again the games took so many
twists and turns it was absolutely
incredible to see and the consensus is
everyone is psyched up for game number
three yeah and even magnus because
magnus carlsen has tweeted right he has
tweeted and there's a little bit of a
cryptic tweet but you know he has posted
the match is unofficially officially on
so i think he's saying yep
look forward to what's about to come
next i i'm struggling to really under
unofficially officially on anyone can
do we get that i think our viewers will
have to help us out with the meaning of
that tweet because a very you know a
clever smile on his face there as well
and of course we want people to keep
tweeting today of course you know the
match has been absolutely incredible so
far and we want you at home to be very
much involved in this experience so
we're asking you to send us your selfies
show us where you're watching the match
from who you're watching the match with
and of course you can also send us your
move suggestions your thoughts anything
funny that comes to mind and you can do
all this by tweeting us by using the
hashtag c24 live yep definitely go ahead
you guys and well david if the match
keeps going like what we've seen in the
first two days i guess we're in for a
lot of entertainment yep a lot of
entertainment and it feels like we're
edging to water decisive result the
first two games despite the fact they
were draws they were full of twists and
turns and both players clinging on at
some point it's not going to be easy for
them to kind of maintain that tension to
maintain their nerves and uh yeah as
we've all mentioned as judith mentioned
herself so much entertainment and that
is set to continue i can't see any
boring games between these guys for the
rest of the match all right and that
leads me into the predictions challenge
that you all can join in of course uh on
magnus nepo the prediction challenge
it's kind of a world championship match
fantasy game where you can challenge
your friends and the entire chess
community we are all playing how are you
guys doing
despite david not playing yesterday i'm
still in bottom place now
well that goes to show how
absolutely random it is and also how um
well good you have to be with your
predictions so i'm taking a little bit
of a gamble today i'm predicting that
this game is actually going to be
shorter than the games we've seen so far
so how many moves i've predicted 35
moves that's quite short i think the
game is going to finish in a draw and my
reasoning for this is because the games
so far have been incredibly intense
they've been tough and required a lot a
lot of endurance so i'm thinking they
might take it easy today now this is a
gamble on my behalf and i don't think
that napoli actually is going to repeat
opening with a kingsporn opening yeah
what do you think simon what's your
predictions for this game who's going to
win pretty much your opposite to your
banker there i have to say so yeah
you're going to be going to go against
your banker but um i'm thinking it's
going to follow probably the the opening
of the first game so we're going to see
this e4
e5 stuff i don't think h3 will be played
so if any anyone at home can remember
this move but i think some kind of
anti-marshal and i expect a long game i
expect like i'm going to go like i think
i said 65 moves something like this and
obviously a draw at the end
they're going to give it a little go but
yeah sounds a lot more thrilling to me
you know 35 moves and a win no the draw
oh sorry oh i thought you but i put in a
win for you on a pony at you with the
white pieces and he looked fierce
yesterday how about you david oh i'm
boring i went for the draw as well i was
about to choose your suggestion uh kai
actually i said napomnechi might win the
first game in the prediction challenge
and today i was close to saying that as
well because he has the white pieces
because he's itching to win but uh draw
roy lopez 42 moves that's my project
i'm going to beat you guys if viana
pognancy wednesday i'm going to score 10
points and you guys can of course also
join in the predictions challenge so you
will have some time to put your
predictions for game three and now
because we're gonna have a short
commercial break we'll be back in a few
minutes
[Music]
[Applause]
today more than ever when the world
comes together to create a better
tomorrow
it's going to be
larger
magic
magic with music with architecture with
colors magic with celebration with your
safety
from here there and everywhere for six
whole months day and night join the
making of a new world starting october
1st
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the new chess 24 playing
experience play in light mode or dark
mode choose from a range of time
controls or create a custom game
and get paired with players from around
the world fast
enjoy a polished playing experience
while making moves on a fresh responsive
board to claim your victories train and
improve with over 80 000 puzzles and
that's not all
download now and discover what more you
can enjoy in our brand new app
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chess skills with the world champion
magnus carlson
[Music]
the magnus trainer app is packed with
fun mini games in interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the magnus trainer available in the app
store and google play
[Applause]
is here arriving the arena in dubai
ready for
game three he's gonna have the white
pieces he did
impress everyone yesterday with some
fantastic moves
and the question is what does he and his
coach vladimir potkin have up their
sleeve for game three today with the
white pieces jana pogniacci he is 31
years old playing his very first world
championship match he did learn chess at
the age of
four and here he is
looking sharp and ready for
game three in dubai in the world
championship match can he score his
first win in the match
as mentioned he did learn chess at the
age of four and he was what
some people would call one of those
child
prodigies not only in chess also when it
came to several subjects in school we
have been to brienne's where jan was
born and where he grew up and we have
talked to some people that knew him
growing up
i was born in soviet union yes still
soviet union in brian it's about
400 kilometers southwest from moscow
now we are in the english classroom
where young
learnt english he was a very curious boy
with big brown very expressive eyes
full of curiosity and a lot of questions
i think i was pretty usual child i
didn't really
like to study yeah i would prefer you
know
some video games some simple like dandy
or sega and of course like some football
and some other active games with friends
he was very serious kid so
very nice looking
he was very stubborn i should say and he
liked fighting with guys so he had lots
of problems
i think he was a bit different because
he was a bit smaller because he joined
school quite early but
it was quite clear from the very
beginning that
he's very talented
as he was very little he usually sat on
his knees
sometimes
i could see him emoji himself into his
world of chess
and forgot about everything he worked
hardest i ever met regarding chess
i would say i'm not sure he gave up
something but of course he had much less
free time than we used to have
during english class
he was asked a question about his
favorite flower as usual children say
rose
lily
but young asked me
how it will be in english syrian
and i suddenly forgot
it in english
and i saw a smile on his face it was his
victory over me
he could combine playing chess
with great success in all subjects
he took part in olympia of different
levels in math
in russian and he always became the
winner i remember that both of us had
serious problems with painting teachers
we had always
clear thing that he would have the gold
medal
but
he could lose it because of the painting
i definitely think that he's not strict
he's very kind-hearted he's very
emotional
he is always ready to
you know to give more than to take
and that's quality of champion i'm sure
he
left school at the age of 16.
and i think that it was the happiest day
in his day here
i could uh
show you this photo ryan is smiling
during his last school day because now
he can emerge himself and devote himself
entirely to chairs
[Music]
janna pomnyacci grew up in briansk and
his teacher and friends still big fans
of him and uh we mentioned he definitely
was a child prodigy in chess and i
understand tanya that you're also
standing with what we should call a
chess prodigy
hello to everyone from dubai cair
right about that i do have a special
guest with me now today is a very
special day here at the dubai expo at
the world championship match it is the
final game before the first rest day
and that means different dynamics come
into play with the opening approach the
players are going to have now in these
matches it's really often about finding
out what the opposing team has prepared
what is their core opening and with one
white one black both these teams have
figured that out so what is it going to
be is it going to be a safety first
approach going into the rest day or will
we see the same entertaining chess that
we've been seeing in game one and game
two to take us through more of that i've
got with me the second youngest
grandmaster in history a rising star in
the chess world gokesh
welcome
welcome hi
hi gakesh now you are here participating
in the world school tournament it's your
first time at a world championship match
how's the experience
actually i've been
in chennai 2013 but not not very close
and just just one day i went there and
yeah this is my second time
we know you've been playing a tournament
here but you've also been following game
one and game two what do you think about
the excitement that we witnessed
yeah both these games i mean even
even if even though it is the start it
has been really exciting and
in both games i think
both players had winning chances um
but okay it was it was well played by
both and i think two draws is fine but
the game's very extremely exciting
absolutely and what do you think is
going to happen today i mean we've got
we've got the rest day coming up yan
starts with the white pieces are we
going to see a marshall auntie marshall
what's your prediction
i would probably say some anti marshal
though i would i think h3 my anti
marshal is not very likely but
and it might be some other anti-martial
or
he might even try to um play d one dot
d4 to see what magnus has prepared there
um
because
the next day is rest day so
um i don't know but i would say anti
martial
and uh if it is an anti-martial now
magnus is knight a5 in game one he got a
good position do you think magnus would
mix it up
i'm not very sure um
he might repeat it because it was quite
convincing i think and
um though i mean bishop b7 and d6 are
all also possible maybe d6 he won't play
but bishop b7 is
uh is possible so
yeah
although i don't think h3 anti-martial
is very likely yeah okay i've got to ask
you now of course uh you're one of the
rising stars of chess you follow their
games very closely as a top-level
grandmaster yourself what do you think
is magnus's big strength and yan's big
strength
um jan's big strength has always been
his aggressive style and
also his time management it's i mean
sometimes he plays simple subjects but i
think
i mean he has managed it now and
candidates he was also very solid and
practical so
yeah and magnus's strength i mean
it always he had too many
yeah awesome and finally tell us what
it's like to be in dubai here uh you're
part of team polgar that won the
challenges chess store how's the
experience been so far
yeah it's very nice to be here in dubai
i'm i'm enjoying playing the world
school event also
yeah it's it's really nice to be here
thank you so much gukesh for that thank
you
so there we have it gakesh predicting
that we might have a repeat by magnus
but the h3 line that we saw that yan
played 95 ideas
who knows what's going to happen i'm
going to go with one e4 by yan and we'll
see how it progresses back to you guys
in the studio all right thank you tanya
and uh the game starts in seven minutes
game three so let's see what the players
come up with in the opening good cash
there only
15. he's 15 now he became a grandmaster
at 12 years old the third youngest in
history after uh emmanuel mishra and
sergey karjakin so a phenomenal talent
i've played it myself he's going to go
far wow yeah and we did mention a chess
prodigy jana pomnyacci also seemed to be
a chess prodigy excellent quite young
only four years old you're born in the
same year david both you yan and magnus
when when do you remember meeting y'all
for the first time i remember greece in
the year 2000 we were both about 9 years
old 10 years old and we actually played
in the european under 10 championship
and i just remember this cute little
smiley kid he would always bring a
notebook with him to every game with
handwritten chess moves in them and he
would sit on that notebook for luck
during each game and
our first encounter was a draw and he
won the gold medal i got the silver and
i don't know i we got on really really
well and uh you could tell even back in
those days he was so determined so
stubborn and uh that helped his chest i
think he was so focused on the chest
just like his school teachers said so
yeah big talent when he was young what
is jan known for simon and the chess
world his styles or what what is he
known for
um well generally he's a very aggressive
player um so we kind of seen that a bit
i think in the second game he missed his
chance there and i'd like to see him in
this game i mean i did say he'd probably
gonna go e4 but i'd love to see him push
that d pawn and just go for something a
little bit more unbalanced and a little
bit more um put some pressure on magnus
the danger i'm thinking though is that
it's the day before the rest day you
lose this game and you're going to be
quite scared you know you go into the
rest day you have to think about it and
that's a major
major problem so will they want to risk
that or come out fresh and try after the
rest day but i hope it's d4 but i'm
expecting the king's pawn to be pushed
all right well it's interesting you said
that because i've been told that magnus
has now also arrived the arena in dubai
like
yesterday spending
five to ten minutes in his car together
with peter heine nelson before
leaving so
what would it sound so strange david
wouldn't they have planned everything
before this yeah you would have thought
so maybe peter heiner nielsen magnus's
coach and uh and his charge maybe
they're just discussing openings maybe
it's just a motivational chat maybe
they're just meditating together who
knows but uh either way there we see
another good friend another magnus just
helping him with some bags and yeah um
strange
maybe magnus just calming those last
minute nerfs emerging now with a smile
on his face look at that after 10
minutes in the car with his coach peter
ryan and nelson coming out with a black
suit playing with the black pieces today
and a big smile on his face and
you talk about the draining simon that
it is the day before
the rest day
but is this also ivanka a good
possibility for magnus because i
he
he is saying that he is you know maybe
last longer than jana pomnyacci that he
is
you know yeah this is physically trained
that this could be a game for him to go
for the kill right this could be a
critical game for him to strike and
especially when you consider what's
happened in game one and two both games
emotionally very draining
very very complex positions they've had
to use a lot of brain power and we've
kind of traditionally thought that you
know magnus is the fit you know
physically fit guy you know and he's the
one who's able to string on the games
for hours and hours on end so it might
be the right time to pounce um
but it could also be a situation where
the players just think hang on you know
it's been an intense start let's
just take a rest and
wait and see and take the action in game
four how would you balance it david so
uh going into the rest day with a loss
if you push too hard devastating or
you know the other player may be a
little drained maybe it is the
possibility to go for a win uh you know
me kaya i just like my long games i just
like sitting at the board and playing
and i think the players they need to get
all the thoughts of future games out of
their mind they need to take it game by
game in general in world championship
matches that's the key so just pour
everything into this game they can chill
tomorrow they can reassess tomorrow or
recover from that defeat tomorrow but i
think just focus on today and magnus he
was smiling he was looking in a relaxed
mood and
he will arrive at the board soon
meanwhile the pontiac waiting for him
it's going to be so exciting to see what
yana pognati in his second game with the
white pieces brings to the board today
will it be the same that he did in game
one that is what simon is predicting
something of the same we did say however
that
magnus was maybe the winner of the
opening stage in game one yeah on paper
it was a roughly equal position but
magnus got his type his style of
position and uh he also got in maybe the
first small surprise and handshake
they're getting ready to go all right
what will it be and is it we see maurice
actually in the background
grandmaster himself will he make the
first move or is he here just to
announce the beginning of it
where he's also the person who leads the
press conferences in dubai incredible
uh usually there is a guest making the
ceremonial first move we'll see whether
that happens today
the players aren't obliged to stick to
that first move of course
g for ginger
if you really want to shake things up a
little bit and
actually that's one thing that we very
rarely see in world championship matches
are surprises on the first move uh
usually players are very strictly
sticking to one e4 or one d4 i do
remember one surprise though and that
was uh vishy anand against gary kasparov
where he played the scandinavian on move
one ooh and what first move would that
be that would have been uh
it would have been to a response to the
king's pawn opening it would have been
actually picking up the queen's pawn and
moving at two squares directly
challenging the pawn don't often see
that move at all so that's not your bet
today then uh gary won i think
yep but uh anand had a great position
though
for scandinavian yeah well the guests
the special guests are arriving and both
players seem to not focus on that they
seem to be deep into
thought and
the special guest will make the first
move let's see if that's what y'all
wants to go for or if it's going to take
the piece back
okay
one d4 has been played by the guest will
we see nepal actually retract that move
taking it back taking it back he's not
letting it
stand e4 clocks are starting
and we're going to see what opening
janopomona she brings to the table in
game three here we go
hey he's pushed e4 he's going e4 oh okay
he's pushed his king's pawn
yes he has indeed and
magnus reacts
in kind also pushing his kingsporn we're
heading in the same path as game one
simon my prediction might have been
correct i know you wanted to see d4 but
uh yeah i'm a little bit upset i have to
say because uh the marshall kind of
things well you know these guys are
analyze those positions so well
that it's quite likely you know they're
gonna get to a position which is just uh
could could be drawn out okay
um so we'll see anyway after knight c6
he's paused on move three so she's gonna
come out
yeah yeah it has okay well it should be
five
there goes my prediction challenge yeah
complete replica so far of the game uh
on day one it's the spanish i was
wondering whether there might be an
italian white developing the bishop to a
different square that is really topical
really popular right now but still the
players playing quickly and copying
their first game so uh black bringing
the night out white castling the king
will we see magnus repeat the opening we
mentioned that maybe he was quite
successful there
if so he does continue he brings his
bishop out one square and in that last
game jan apology slid his rook across
he's doing the same again okay so we're
still in game one still in game one
who's gonna blink first who's going to
be coming up with those new moves those
new ideas who's gonna get the first
surprise in that is the key right now
still copying game one white bishop has
been attacked it has to retreat
and uh in that game magnus now castled
as black he castled his king he's done
it again
uh look at magnus body language not so
energetic right now but he knows that
this was predictable he knows that uh
he's done this all before he's seen it
all before okay
and uh janna ponnecchi this is actually
the key moment that simon mentioned last
time he picked up his pawn on the other
side of the wall he's h-porn it's the
first new move of the world championship
match he's played an anti-martial but
it's a different anti-marshal he's
pushed a pawn on the other side okay the
queen side
and uh still very popular move but
magnus slightly frowning and pausing and
it seems yana pomniacci leaving the
board here he's expecting magnus now to
take the pause and think about what to
do next yep uh magnus won't be that
surprised by this move magnus has had
this position probably hundreds of times
before with both white and with black
but
it wasn't what napoli actually employed
last time so
um here i'm expecting magnus to think
for maybe one or two minutes
i think napoli actually are also
expecting that and once magnus replies
he'll get back to the board
here black has a few options he can push
the black b pawn forward the black pawn
has just been attacked by white pawn i
can push it forward one square he can
develop his bishop this is the older
move this is the more classical move he
could also have moved to rook
uh daniel dubov a very famous russian
player has also employed a very uh
ambitious pawn sacrifice in that
position but no magnus just developing
his bishop protecting the black rook in
that top corner just in case there is a
set of pawn trades and uh
yeah relatively standard stuff so far
what is the name of this opening then
it's still the anti-marshal okay the
anti-marshal which is a branch of the
royal lopez from the spanish opening so
roy lopez is uh
the the big
the name of the big thing big opening
yeah winning prediction today or lopez
yeah so david have you had this position
many times yourself bishop b7 seems like
a normal move there yes yeah um i've got
fond memories of this position from the
black side actually i made one of my
grandmaster norms by winning a game with
the black pieces in this exact position
in a final round and i also
in the london chess classic in the first
london chess classic i managed to beat
nihua a very strong chinese player uh
with the black pieces
uh in this position
in order to come third behind carlson
and kramnik actually so i guess we can
uh sort of
say it's going to be quite a long
maneuvering game after this opening um
both sides just no exchanges anytime so
pieces around and playing this so uh
yeah but pretty equal this opening so
far
okay pretty equal but uh both sides will
have their ideas so
yeah each player just pushing a pawn in
the center just solidifying their
structure
simon have you had much experience in
either side of these not at all no i
normally always go uh push my pawn to f4
remove two
which is
done against me i have done it against
you yeah yeah i mean actually
interestingly yan
did a chess ball course on the on the
king's gambit which is an opening where
you give up a pawn on the second move
but
at this level um what made yesterday's
game so surprising
was the fact that you know there was
lots of sacrifices the pawn exchange
from magnus but generally you can't get
away with sacrificing pawns earlier on
you know in in world championship games
so standard maneuvering here both sides
just getting their pieces to to decent
squares to start the game
yeah uh i mean i love attacking kind of
romantic openings like the king's gambit
but just too much risk involved high
reward but also high risk and
especially in an early stage
it makes sense to go back to this type
of maneuvering quieter opening
and what do you think of uh janna
pomnyacci's choice you know this is very
much following all the main
ideas of this position i mean is there
any scope for surprises in this or is it
kind of like well-trodden paths and
maybe maybe the position might just
fizzle out yeah i think the surprises
will come a bit later on both sides for
sure would have analyzed this position
and it's not actually about memorizing
exact variations long uh forcing lines
it's more about where to put the pieces
about the long-term plan so
if napoleon actually and carson they've
both studied this position i wouldn't
have been surprised if they played
training games for example against their
coaches just to see okay i'm comfortable
with my pieces on this side of the board
or
this is my plan over the next 10 15
moves
and despite the fact magnus is thinking
he's just maybe just trying to recall
how he felt most comfortable placing his
pieces so no surprises yet i don't see
this one fizzling out anytime soon i
think this will be a long game as simon
mentioned
yeah
and i'm just checking actually i'm
searching this position on g chess
and
i have to say i have to say you know ghs
is quite unusual and that's the first
ever website where you can just put up a
position and you can search that
position over chess databases chess
articles even youtube and of course
chessable as well and here i'm just
seeing that there's a lot of articles on
this particular move you know and
they're telling me right now that
kasparov prepared this move for his
1993 encounter with nigel short
and that was also another world
championship match
and uh lots of information here
apparently the old main line has
actually developed the night to a
different location and everyone everyone
used to do that
uh so all the hot stuff right now
it's the place to be it is yeah ivanka
so maybe talk us through you mentioned
that developing the knight to a
different square is the main line this
one was the old main line old main line
sorry this would have put more pressure
on this pawn this is where i have more
experience as well but white uh napoli
actually may be with a small surprise
not choosing the most active square
choosing
maybe a slightly more passive square for
now but he wants to re-route his knight
towards the king side
ah
so all the action will be on the king's
side that's right actually in this
opening the most common plan for example
if black makes a move is to park the
knight next to its fellow here
again if black makes a move and these
two knights together they're great
defenders but they can be great
attackers as well later on
yeah very tense position
there was a lot of chat yesterday about
potentially who the seconds could be for
the players and
i'm guessing the way they play the
openings like playing this knight out in
front of the queen knight to d2
you have to ask to do any of the seconds
likely maybe sergey karakin i know he
played a lot of positions like this
could he be helping you know obviously
played magnus for the world
championships as well but he liked this
kind of slow maneuvering idea and he
tried this in that world championship
match against magnus carson which of
course ended in a number of draws but
it's kind of i still think this this
staged world championships a bit of a
sparring match they haven't really got
involved yesterday they did get involved
but they're still trying to suss each
other out with their openings and 92 is
yeah it's it's maybe slightly well not
slightly peculiar but it's a different
path to the main line and uh well sergey
kirakin has posted on social media from
dubai so he has at least been there
maybe he's still there and uh also
talking about this opening every day
chessable
makes a free course available on the
opening of today uh and today's course
is young gustav sons e5 for black and
you can check it out
on the link in the bottom of the screen
so while these players are playing out
this game you can dig deeper into the
same kind of opening on chasebo so have
two screens open
watch this watch the game unfold and
also
dig deeper into the position yeah i mean
that's a huge opportunity to learn from
a world-class grandmaster like jan
gustafsson famous commentator but also
someone who has worked with magnus
carson in the past it's rumored he might
be part of the team now nobody knows but
jan gustafsson he's one of the biggest
experts
on this opening from the black side and
simon mentioned sergey karyakin who has
experience on both sides of this type of
position as well
um also for example peter lecko who
helped janna panetchi in the candidates
match uh earlier this year he's a big
expert from the black side
and uh yeah lots of names come to mind
but younger stuff since course there i
think i think peter is is a second
doesn't he for uh i believe for yan um
but it's very likely right i think i was
doing commentary on one of the events
that you guys are doing and uh peter was
saying he was unavailable i think it's
very likely that peter has a second for
yan during his match which uh which i
don't know he's a good second to have
he's a great theoretical player so kind
of guy you want behind you i mean i
think it's interesting i think magnus
and his team
tends to go for seconds who he gets on
well with maybe more than just picking
the best kind of the best players in
those openings he wants someone who
he likes because they spend a lot of
time together probably in training camps
that's right yeah and just to get good
vibes of them to feel good but maybe jan
is picking players i don't know he
probably likes them as well but he's
picking players an expert in those
openings so it's slightly different
approaches i guess with who you're
getting behind you as a team and the
team is so important i feel like um i
mean david you nearly qualified for the
candidates recently i don't bring it up
again too much but uh it was it was
great to see we're all cheering for you
and
if you were if you got to the candidates
would you
i mean what would be your approach would
you would you like a second do you like
working your own i mean do you think
it's important to have
someone who's an expert in the openings
or someone who can maybe help you a
little bit yeah just emotionally i would
love to kind of have that team around me
just to kind of take the burden off in
terms of doing the work to keep those
good vibes going to feed you with new
ideas you always need some kind of
inspiration at this top level
you can't just keep doing the same thing
over and over again so yeah i would have
loved to have found some seconds i'm not
sure who i would have asked or um who i
would have found but apart from this guy
apart from simon actually i was thinking
a few years ago that you'd be the dream
second for me just because sometimes i
kind of get in a bit of a funk and i i
lose a bit of creativity and just to
feed the ideas but just very kind yeah
i'm not just saying that as well i was
thinking genuinely and uh on the other
side i've been lucky enough to be a
second for a couple of top players and
uh just get a bit of insight into their
regime and how things work and yeah it's
intense uh once the chest starts so
that's why magnus i think wants those
people around here that he gets on with
yeah what about you that's good
we just saw a move there from magnus
carlsen and i just kind of wanted to
point out that this is not the main move
in this position and actually just
checking the database i can see is like
the fifth most popular move so magnus
carlsen doing what magnus carlsen does
best which is choosing those sidelines
which the opponent might not necessarily
has have studied and uh okay the main
the best actually the most popular move
was actually to attack the bishop with
the knight i put it on the a5 square but
uh
magnus says no he wants a lot more
flexibility in the position so he's
decided just to move the rook and uh now
my uh jana palmierche has taken a pause
and i can tell you that the most popular
move
after that rogue move is actually just
to move the knight away from its d2
square and that's it as david
highlighted before just relocate the
knight to f1 and then move it on to
greener pastures yeah so very thematic
stuff so far the players will be
familiar with these patterns these ideas
it's just uh they will be deciding which
order and which to use them and uh
there's maybe one thing you and napolita
is also considering because black's rook
move has weakened the defense of a
square weakened the defense of a pawn
this pawn now is only defended by the
black king it is tied up by the white
bishop so possibly you could consider
jumping forward with this knight and
causing a double attack and uh this
would cause a big question to magnus
would he be forced to repeat and uh
retreat his rook back to where it came
from to defend this important pawn or
would he be able to push a pawn forward
and block this bishop's diagonal this
would lead to a lot of crazy
complications uh and uh maybe janna
pogba actually having been surprised by
magnus's last move only the fifth most
popular choice this rook move maybe he's
thinking okay do i react just simply and
calmly by retreating my knight or do i
get aggressive and try and punish him
for playing a move i haven't looked at
before
and uh what do we think guys is that too
ambitious
is that uh
this knight jump it would be on my radar
but i'm not sure i would be brave enough
to go for it
well it has it has good stats in its
favor
yeah exactly well only three games is a
very small pool but uh three games and
uh three victories for white oh wow
that's 100 yeah it is
it would kind of beg the question right
and say to
magnus hey do you want to repeat the
position three times or do you want to
take risks this this seems to be like
one of magnus's ideas especially in the
first two games he played this knight a5
move and yesterday he played this knight
e5 move he's the he's seems to be the
first person to play something a little
bit unusual in his previous games and as
this is the the fifth choice he's doing
that again and i i generally think
that's a very clever idea if you get the
first slight surprising just to just to
draw your opponent out of what they're
they're used to playing uh okay we see
we see another move here david uh well
i'm sure this is a move you played many
times in this position as well knight to
f1 did you play this position frankie
you're more d4 player is that right yeah
i i never liked these type of positions
i did try around about 2007 2008 to play
these kind of positions but there was
too many pieces on the board and too
much tension and not enough clear pawn
breaks for me so i decided nope
not for me switched to playing the 1d4
yeah actually it's a bit like yesterday
um completely different opening of
course but there weren't that many
trades there weren't that many exchanges
of pieces at least yesterday for the
first 20 or so moves and
it looks like we're heading in that
direction again today just maneuvering
and um it's all about planning here it's
not about tactics it's not about any
dynamism it's pure planning and
strategic play and that's why maybe i
was always attracted to these types of
openings when i was
kind of progressing through the ranks
but it also means they're extremely
difficult to handle
if you go for the wrong plan
things might get tricky for you yeah
it's all about timing as well i remember
the very first train i had you know when
he tried to explain to me these type of
positions he just said it's about timing
you want to catch your opponent on the
wrong foot
and
but again patience is the key there
and i do have a question from paul on
twitter who says that they heard that
the players can see a computer screen
view off the board in the player's
lounge when they step away from the
board what are your views on this
especially when it's an over-the-board
championship
that's interesting
i think it's just commonplace it's kind
of normal nowadays to have a board it's
usually for spectators of course so that
they can see
uh see what's going on but for the
players it's
i mean it's strange looking at a board
compared to looking at the screen is
completely different but at the same
time maybe nepali napolita that maybe
that's why he was away from the board so
much yesterday just because he felt more
relaxed looking at a computer screen
looking at uh i kind of find it a bit
weird that you can sit in the chill-out
room or you can just look at the
electronic
i mean it's sort of like you know you
just maybe have your banana or sandwich
and the other guy's sitting at the board
maybe they shouldn't be allowed to have
screens back there i i mean it's a
different look because you kind of get
used to the obviously we play a lot
online but you're playing on the board
so the adjustment is quite hard but
i find it a bit strange i don't know i
find it like you know because they don't
need to be at the board then and it's
like there's maybe more mind games
coming into it i mean i can remember one
world championships it was uh cram nick
versus tapalof
and um they had their room behind which
they could go to and there's a lot of
controversy there where kramnik was
going to the room quite a lot and to
paul off actually accused him of
cheating because he was disappearing so
toilet gate
it was indeed a toilet gate yeah the
toilet gate scandal so uh you know um so
it's it's a bit strange to me i mean i i
don't know if they should have those
screens there personally yeah because
you can you can remember the position
anyway so um maybe it will encourage
them to spend more time in their in
their chill-out room yeah so it could be
cool as well then they would always have
to go and check has he made his move has
he made his move now they obviously know
on the screen when the move happens and
i do wonder what are the kind of rules
on chess like whether you you're allowed
to be in your lounge
when you know that your clock is ticking
and
yeah because i mean i've i've always
just rushed back to my board yeah yeah i
mean that's just i mean i mean
historically that's usually what we see
right so we were very surprised
yesterday when pogba actually spent most
of the time on his clock
in his lounge and when he was ready to
make his move when he was finished sort
of analyzing and thinking
then he came to the board and made the
move very strange especially because if
he was looking on the screen the screens
are always shown from the white side and
he had black yesterday so it would have
been a bit of a
uh how do i say this a bit of a it would
have scrambled his mind a bit
i could think of a word yeah okay i was
going for that one okay
yeah it would have scrambled his mind a
bit to look on a screen from the white
side but mine scrambled
sitting at the board it would have been
a completely different feeling like
ivanka says kind of again it's chess
etiquette just general behavior you're
not supposed to leave the board if you
while it's your move
and if he knows it's his move is he
obliged to return can he just sit there
and chill i think that's that is the
weird question because like obviously
you know if you sure move at the board
and you suddenly get off and walk out
the hall it's like what's going on this
is really rude i don't even know if it's
illegal to do that you're not allowed to
do
i've had situations where i've been in
the okay so we do have a move bishop d2
bishop moves to the d2 square okay so
far so good um i can see on the database
quite a few games about 20 games so far
and a few grand masters have played this
position on the black side and one
significant name that jumps out of me is
uh on the white side gary kasparov
against vladislav
in a rapid game so we do do we think
gary is jan's second oh is that has that
potential has has gary done a bit of a
skype call over to yann yeah that would
be a headline we want it back in russia
come on
get on the case i'll help you out for a
day or two well notoriously uh carlson
did work with uh gary caspar so he would
know a lot about magnus even if magnus
was quite young right when he worked
with gary caspar was around 2008 2009 i
think okay so it's just while magnus was
about to get to world number one i
remember i played magnus in 2009 and he
used an opening idea against me that he
just picked up from gary kasparov a few
weeks earlier and oh it was scary to
face but
but yeah somehow it feels like maybe
because kasparov probably isn't in his
training camp i don't think so yeah
it's gary playing it all now i mean
obviously not you know professionally
but is he sometimes showing up to some
events and playing he's played two
tournaments over this year yeah really
yeah one of them didn't go so well um it
was a rapid blitz event and maybe it was
just a bit of rust
uh but then the next tournament he
played i think it was the uh fischer
random the chess 960 and he did very
well there actually uh at some point he
has he had big chances of winning it
ahead of such names as aronian and
nakamura
yeah yeah he did very very well there so
still he's still got it it's just hard
to get much fit again yeah but you know
he has such an aura that when when he
plays chess i always think that he's got
a chance of winning the tournament even
though i know that he hasn't been a
professional player for a long long time
i still feel you know what i think he
can do it yeah
16 years retired yeah he's still he's
still a beast exactly and okay so a
position that uh
he has played he has played this move
diana pognati now made
all right
what do you think of the position right
now david is it too early to call if the
players are
ambitious today or i think we could
definitely say that players are
ambitious i mean this whole opening
keeping maximum attention by napoli
actually it shows he's not trying to
guide the game towards a draw or guide
it towards anything safe
um i mean while all the pieces remain it
could go in any direction and it's
purely about understanding and okay
magnus meanwhile retreating his dark
squad bishop out of the way of the black
rook very sensible the black bishop
there acting as the defender of the
black king later on maybe
so still very typical stuff but um i
just i like the tension i like having
all the pawns all the pieces on the
board no trades yet
and uh
can i can i show you the two approaches
okay well no probably actually has made
a very fast move okay this is the main
moving the night again yeah
it is pretty much better there was
another alternative
which would have amped up the tension
even more um and it was actually played
by gary kasparov himself he didn't
actually move the knight to that square
instead he chose to pick up the sea pawn
and
challenge the pawn on b5 by playing c4
so okay that's not so orthodox actually
no i know that's something we very
rarely see in this opening uh because it
does actually block in this bishop and i
think the idea is that if black just
bypasses this pawn if black locks things
up this bishop is a terrible piece i
guess the whole concept is to push this
pawn forward at some point and try and
reopen this bishop it might come at the
cost of a pawn but now this bishop will
eternally be a strong piece so
um very interesting idea from gary
caspar of there let's go to janna
pontiac's move however he chose to bring
his knight to the center first so maybe
this idea is still in the air for later
uh by kerry kasparov and uh this night i
mentioned it going in the other
direction but here it does have its eyes
on two squares
one in the center of the board
this uh will stop any potential pawn
breaks by black black can never push
this pawn forward now the square's
covered too many times but also
the f5 square we've talked about f5 so
many times actually throughout the
course of the champions chess tour and
knight on f5 will thrive i think that's
what kaya came up with and uh yeah
normally that piece landing on that
square will be the signal for an attack
so for example if one can land a knight
on the square it's just a launch pad and
there will be threats of sacrifices
maybe later on maybe white will move the
other night out of the way then start
bringing the queen into the action
and
lots of potential scary ideas for magnus
to face sometimes you will be strict
with the players david when they move
their pieces too many times in the
openings but is this a good plan for
yana pognati even if it will be the
fourth move with the knight fourth move
with the knight and now magnus moves a
piece that's already been developed i
think it's fine in this scenario because
both sides have castled both sides have
moved pretty much all of their pieces
once by now especially their minor
pieces their bishops and knights and
once you've completed development
especially if the center is blocked as
it is at the moment both sides kind of
with nice pawn structures then you do
have the luxury of just maneuvering
and while the moves are continuing
absolutely i've seen the evaluation bar
as well i mean i i hate looking at the
evaluation bar so much and it this
happened yesterday and one thing i would
advise actually is to try not to look at
it too much sometimes because it just
jumps around maybe doesn't catch up but
it really jumped there after magnus's
night move but that can't be a bad move
this is standard stuff right it is the
main move and uh now the idea that that
we kind of showed earlier that gary
kasparov used
is now being put into operation it is
now maximum tension on that b5 pawn and
wow okay now this is interesting because
the main response is actually to
actually reinforce that pawn
and
create even more all sorts of suspense
and
i want to say tension again
in that side of the board but uh magnus
he chooses something else and he goes
for porn taste porn and we kind of sense
the pattern actually jana pomnierti has
been incredibly well prepared but it
looks like magnus has just gone that one
move deeper i mean the one thing that
amazed me with magnus carlsen i mean we
talked about yan following gary
kasparov's game here which i'm sure he's
aware of
as you know magnus very well david it's
just magnus's memory
is is phenomenal
um the one story i can remember was he
was playing well i don't think he was
playing but he came over to reykjavik
and they have this chess pub quiz over
in reykjavik and uh there's 20 questions
but the questions are the hardest ever
chess questions you can get they're
incredibly hard and you get all these
historians coming over just to do this
pub quiz and uh i think the highest
score someone's got is like 17 and
that's a team of four he came over with
hammer so hammertime and he took part in
it and apparently hammer's really bad at
these quizzes
just mainly just magnus doing it and he
got 19 and a half out of 20. and it was
it was random positions from games
played 200 years ago and you had to name
the players and name was going on and he
just knew it straight away and it's just
a phenomenal photographic memory so i'm
sure in this position he's well aware of
the c4 idea and he has some good ideas
about what to do
just like jan does
yeah and we see magnus there just taking
a step away from the board still
studying the position though and uh i
wouldn't be surprised as you mentioned
simon if he's completely familiar with
that kasparov game and uh despite the
fact both players now they've spent
about 10 15 minutes on the clock
i think both players have actually
looked at this exact position before
and uh if not this exact position that
at least the same ideas and black has
just captured a pawn which way do we
think he's going to recapture with white
with a knight with a bishop
i mean
sorry frank i i was just thinking i mean
if you take the bishop is that i mean is
there ever a d5 move you have to worry
about i'm not sure but
um if you take with a pawn you might
lose the pawn so
um i don't know maybe bishop takes us
his or knight takes you and knight takes
coming to a5 looks like a good plan yeah
we could definitely make an argument for
two recaptures here i'm expecting white
to take back with the knight personally
but um taking back with the bishop here
for white also very very sensible
let's see
only two games in the database okay and
uh what was the move played there did
white recapture that pawn with the
bishop we're about to find out what
napoleon she's going to do with the
knights they they captured the title or
the bishop it didn't really matter okay
certain knight
captures the pawn
okay so white tonight you mentioned it
kaya it's moved so many times
let's count one two three four times now
this knight has moved but is the aim
still to get to the f5 thriving square
or is that plan now off the board i
think that plan for now is off the board
because magnus actually very cleverly
retreated the black knight to cover that
important f5 square so black's knight
now the one sitting in front of the
black rock on e7 that yeah that piece
was doing a purely defensive job and it
persuaded napoli actually to go away
from his plan and that's why the top
players are so good they're flexible if
they go for one plan if it's stopped
then they'll switch to a different plan
and probably actually instead of going
for the black king that we mentioned
maybe is one potential idea he's going
instead for the other side of the board
so do you think because you mentioned
ivanka that
getting to that f5 square with the night
for jana pomnyacci uh had a very good
score three games yep three wins yeah
will magnus have been aware of that and
then made his plan to make sure
janupomona is not able to go to that
square
um yeah i think magnus chose that
particular move order because i think he
wanted to play those mind games again
with janna pomney actually does napomni
actually just
tried to repeat the position or not and
uh
you know take the risk that maybe things
get very very sharp very quickly and now
the game is kind of taking a different
turn it's about maneuvering the pieces
again getting ready to put your pieces
on ideal squares and of course getting
ready to open up the position it's all
about the nights it is all about the
nights yeah they're doing a merry dance
right now he's moved the night again so
uh back to where it came from just a few
moves ago
interesting and very surprised david
yeah i mean i
i'm slightly just well i'm surprised but
also impressed that magnus has clearly
studied this position beforehand even
though
i mean it's so rare i mean ivanka
mentioned it's only been played once
before this position up until now it's
never been played this last move was the
first new one right first move i can
tell you it has been studied someone
came in october 27
2021 and checked out this position and
there they actually analyzed whites
moving the rook to the c1 square to the
open line and uh did anything else
happen after that let's have a look
october 2021 you said yeah yeah october
27th so just a few which is last month
peter heiner nielsen i'll
and it was on the clouds that
information was available yeah well
because usually you make yourself
anonymous so that people cannot see it
some someone forgot it then
it could be the problem is you can't
check what other people have analyzed
without allowing your information of
what you're analyzing out there as well
so it's a bit of a double-edged sword
yeah and uh okay i mean this is modern
chests for you i mean clearly these are
some of the top computer moves and
that's why it's been analyzed uh maybe
we can just do a bit of a dive into why
magnus has been moving his knight around
so much uh we saw in this position simon
was saying maybe the white bishop can
capture this pawn instead the white
knight took and the white knight now
maybe wants to head actually to the edge
of the board not something we normally
recommend but it would harass this
bishop and this white uh this light
squad bishop would have to retreat this
is actually one of magnus's most
important pieces he cannot let it for
bishops in this type of position as
things are about to become open are very
important that's why magnus brought his
knight back uh back to where it came
from it was only here what three moves
ago and now he stopped the white knight
from going to this square that would
just end in a trade if white were to
bring his knight to the side of the
board we'd see a trade i don't think
this is going to help napoliyachi too
much and i guess the other idea behind
magnus's knight move as well as covering
this square is to cover the central
square to stop white pushing in the
center and opening things up
while black isn't ready so
very strange losing time magnus with
this knight but he has provoked
napoliyachi into showing his hand into
kind of revealing his plan and ivanka
mentioned now this is the move that was
studied by that mysterious anonymous
person online was it peter heiner
nielsen or was it vladimir potkin uh
whose coach was it uh that has studied
this rook move it's very natural
actually just it's a semi-open line you
can have some targets
here for the white rook
yeah i mean they had to exchange your
pawns as well i'm just wondering um if
this favored anyone so you have the open
file for the seabrook
maybe maybe magnus can try to get
something on the b file here i think
whenever you have an exchange of pawns
whenever the structure changes it's a
good idea to take another look at the
position and see what the positives and
negatives are so
you know it seems easier for white to
play this to my eyes because that knight
on c6 could be a bit clumsy so black
should be looking for some counter play
somehow and i'm just trying to work out
where that's going to come from maybe
rook b8 uh d5 is a move you always want
to try but i don't know if d5 is maybe
just not working in this position here
because you drop the pawn next to it if
you if you push on so
it's uh should i tell you what was
studied in october 27th yeah i
considered it i can see so so what was
studied there is that the root came to
that line and the main move that they
had considered was actually pushing the
a pawn one square forward just to secure
the
b4 square
and
then white played
bishop going to c3 just to support a
pawn push
and then okay so bishop retreats back i
don't know why mysterious to me this way
yep back back to its home square and
then really deep i know and then
finally
yes yeah and then white finally pushed
the pawn forward in the center and uh
then that's how capture was analyzed so
what do you think wow
that's a lot of them do you think this
is someone having fun or do you think
this is like
serious moves they look like serious
moves to me um
i think just the fact that you're
analyzing this position rather than some
crazy kings gambit means that you're
you're you're doing it more for work
than fun you know this is not something
you're probably gonna do
if you're playing like you know joe
blogs in the weekend tournament down in
bournemouth or something this is this is
world championships level i think so
okay i think this could be serious
analysis yeah quite possibly and just
the fact maybe that jan is now taking
his time maybe it was from magnus's team
you know let's see
so possibly yeah yeah i mean if it was
one of the annapolis coaches who was
analyzing this position looking at this
rook move then maybe
he passed on that knowledge but maybe
the conclusion was unclear because we're
already at move 16 now that's quite deep
uh remember especially because magnus
played only the fifth most popular
choice a few turns ago
uh there's no way that janna pogba
actually could have gone
even further i think than the next
couple of moves in his analysis and if
it wasn't magnus carson's team
then i think he'll be ready with ideas
such as that bishop retreat you
mentioned ivanka rerouting that black
light squad bishop that one for me
that's
i mean that's not even grandmaster move
that's kind of
uh silicon valley move where the top
computers
he's played rook c1 as well so okay so
if you place a5 now instantly is team
team magnus on on the cloud yeah so this
is what we're thinking that's a good
point simon
pushes that pawn yeah for sure it was
magnus's it must be
would he play it quickly
okay if he sits down and bangs out a5 or
will he like hollywood a little bit i
mean i guess you've both been in a
situation like i i know i have myself
you prepared a novelty and you're able
to get it in so a new idea on the board
um which happens quite rarely but you
know it's a strong idea but rather than
playing it quickly there is a bit of
psychology so you want to you don't want
to show your opponent you've had this
prepared so you kind of sit there you're
really eager to play that move and
they'd say you should sit on your hands
when you're a kid so you you don't go
rushing around your hands but you sit in
your hands you think you know it's a
good move but you're just like i'm going
to let them think that i've only just
worked this out just to get that little
mind game so i don't know if that
happens at this level i mean is that
just me or do you guys ever have that
same kind of slight mind game when you
have a new idea yeah all the time
actually there's two different
approaches uh one of them is the one you
mentioned simon where you just play calm
you pretend you don't know what's going
on but secretly you do and you know
a lot more details the other approach is
to scare your opponent and a lot of top
players do this nakamura does this adi
ban does this uh from my experience they
just bang down the move and they just
hope that their opponents are terrified
by their confidence ah so uh two
different approaches i think and yeah
but we really are now looking for that
pawn move from magnus if he plays that
move he's going to be in preparation
and we know that they've been on the
cloud
they've accidentally made that
information public
that'd be a bit of a mistake though if
they made it public don't you think i
mean if you can uh well well the thing
is though i mean this position is quite
uh it's quite quite rare right so it's
not necessarily kind of clear that
anyone would know that there was it was
them and it's only when we get to this
position we're like aha yeah so that's
who it was and uh just out of curiosity
as well i've just checked sassy which is
of course this norwegian supercomputer
which uh it's basically stockfish but
super powered with high level processes
and he does say that that move is best
okay
i mean come on this is high level stuff
in the world championships already after
16 moves in game three we have a
super interesting and tense moment well
magnus carlsen play
the pawn to a five
i i'm not sure that would be on my radar
to be honest because black's pawn on the
the a pawn if it it is isolated if it
does push forward black's pieces will be
tied down defending it for several moves
so you're basically yes you're taking
control of some important squares but
you're also weakening your own pawn so
it's not human instinct necessarily
of course magnus is strong enough to
make a decision like that and evaluate
it correctly even if he doesn't know the
position but if he does know the
position then and obviously what is the
point with it it's just to take i think
it's to stop white pushing his pawns
forward and gaining space um let's maybe
do a deeper dive just to check it out
one more time because i think there are
two ideas that magnus might need to find
if he wants to hold the balance
firstly it is pushing this pawn forward
and as i mentioned now white does have
two pieces attacking this isolated pawn
which can't be held on to by other black
pawns but it does tie down the black
pieces and the idea i guess is to
control this square so that means that
if white forever to for example retreat
a bishop he could never ever push his
pawn forward it would simply be captured
and also if you delay it too long as
black if you kind of just
make a random move on the other side
then maybe white wants to push his pawn
to this square and this would open up
another nice diagonal for white's bishop
so maybe it's just a kind of a move to
stop the opponent's plans just as much
as to kind of
do anything yourself i'm wondering if
black does push a5 i mean obviously this
is something they may have analyzed if
uh that pawn as you mentioned is very
weak
do you have time to play something kind
of ridiculous i don't think you do uh
because of bishop c8 rook b8 but i'd
like to play rookie two and queen e1 but
that's incredibly slow because you get
your probably bishop c8 is a very good
response but this pawn you've pointed
out on a5 is is a real weakness and uh
you can't defend that pawn in a lot of
lines but sneaky actually that's clever
yeah obviously here black has many ways
to get counter played bishop g4 uh being
one rugby eight being another idea but
you you must watch out for that pawn on
a5 so maybe it's not a very human move
to play pawn to a5 as you said because
you uh put your black pawn under attack
um
so i don't know if he'll find that move
or not really here yeah not easy it's i
mean he's looking up now and normally
that's magnus carlsen's kind of
remembering face where he's just trying
to recall what he studied before
maybe when he recalls it yeah oh that
was it
maybe he's just thinking oh a5 i've seen
that somewhere what was the evaluation
what did my coach say about that
uh yeah it feels like maybe he's
semi-aware that he has discussed this
position before but maybe he doesn't
know all of the exact details yeah i
mean there's so many variations so much
information exactly i mean
you i think magnus from his reaction i
don't think he remembers that with every
little detail
and maybe he doesn't remember the move
that he should be playing here and just
now is on his own and is going to maybe
make another move but okay if if it is
like that he doesn't quite remember but
he goes through the options maybe that
that he thinks are good options and then
he comes maybe to this porn move
would it be like oh wait
ah we did study that we did look at that
that was a good move yeah i think
exactly
sometimes you just get there by process
of elimination or you kind of reverse
engineer your own thinking and
um yeah i mean
simon's mentioned his memory his
phenomenal memory magnus and
um of course there's a huge amount of
data to absorb before any world
championship match you need to cover
every single opening pretty much in
chess but
it's somewhere in his memory banks and
uh maybe he's doing a sherlock holmes
just going into his mind palace right
now
he's clearly not looking at the board so
he's not really looking or kind of
calculating variations he's just trying
to go into recall mode yeah
do you think these players like magnus i
mean i remember anish geary was saying
when he prepares for uh the candidates
obviously another world-class player and
tweeter and when he goes into the
candidates he he has to go over all the
variations of his laptop to maybe get it
from long-term memory into short-term
memory because a lot of these things
they're there but you might look to them
two years ago so can you actually
remember the board do you think someone
like magnus
is capable of doing that i mean you're
talking of hundreds hundreds of
thousands of lines probably uh that go
very deeply it's uh i i guess getting
into short-term memory looking at them
is something quite important you know
yeah yesterday we talked here in the
studio about chess being a bit like uh
chess matches like this being a bit like
exams right even if you know everything
you need to revise just beforehand yeah
just to turn it into that short-term
memory and uh
yeah i mean i've been there when magnus
has been just kind of clicking through
some buttons and
just he can absorb it very quickly or he
can recall very quickly but
if it has been two years since he looked
at it then it's uh not easy for anyone
not two years october 27th
yeah that wasn't him
yeah
and
yeah one thing i was going to say is
that you do have to be very careful when
you're trying to absorb the chest
variations i mean
i the best tip that i can give is for
everyone just to put it up on a board
put up the put up the position that you
want to memorize on a board
and then you can kind of get a feeling
for how the position is maybe the sense
of danger of the human moves as well
i be very careful with just opening up a
chess program and just going
with the space and then you're like
i got that one in reality there's been
no absorption whatsoever because you
haven't put the hard graft into it it's
been the computer that's generated these
moves and you've just gone yes oh and
look at mine i totally agree with you
there i mean i know so many
players who are i don't know let's say
1400 strength and they rely
on their computer as much as they can i
mean one story i was playing in vienna
with another grand master and we had
someone joining us who was 1400 strength
and after the games he would uh we'd go
and have a glass of wine maybe look at
his game uh but he'd like to he
preferred to look at the game on his
phone with the weak fritz so we
suggested moving he'd be like no no no
no the computer says minus 0.2 to that
you're wrong you're wrong and it's like
oh dear and after about an hour that
it's like oh just let's just go and have
a wine somewhere else
none of that please so it's really easy
to get lazy you just look at the phone
but you're not really understanding
why these moves are being suggested and
you have to understand the reasoning
behind the moves that's something that
computers just just can't tell you they
can't tell you the why
so uh it's so important to understand
why is rook c1 for example a good move
or or something else yeah well magnus
here still in deep thought will he make
this uh a5 move with his pawn we're
going to head down to tanya standing
with a lot of great chess waves what do
you think tanya will magnus make this
a5 move
we're gonna find out but the one thing
that's very clear is that this is going
to be a long strategic fight quite
different from the action that we've
been witnessing in game one and game two
uh and for more on that for more
insights about the kind of chess we're
seeing today going into the rest day
tomorrow i've got with me grandmaster
maurice ashley maurice thank you for
joining us thank you so much for having
me tanya maurice first impressions about
the position that we have on the board
right now i love it it's
playing into the same kind of strategy
actually that they've had so far
atypical positions you don't see this
kind of rue lopez every single day this
plan of c4 taking on c4 knight c4 the
pawn structure is atypical that is what
we're seeing and that puts magnus sort
of on his back foot because he's not
able to just play relaxed moves let me
do this let me do that i know all this
no he's got to think he's a unique
position that jana has prepared i like
this kind of chess i have to ask you now
maurice
this is magnus's second black he's had
two blacks he's gone for the marshall
he's made it clear andy marshall by yan
here first he played h3 then he's gone
for a4 now one of the players is of
course known for
anti-martial where he won a big game
peter lecko peter beat kramnik in a very
very important game in the martial
magnus giving it away that his main prep
against e4 is the marshall what do you
think about that well magnus is magnus
he can do what he wants he doesn't care
about peter lako he doesn't care about
vladimir kramnik fischer kasparov his
name is magnus carlson because he knows
everything he is comfortable playing any
position we've seen him play openings
the dragon he'll just toss it out there
because he feels like it his
understanding is so deep that any
position he's in he feels like he's like
a cat you throw him out a window he's
gonna flip and land on his feet
awesome now maurice of course you're a
grandmaster you're a pro commentator and
i have to ask you i worked with you in
st louis as well you have a great
understanding of players their style the
last two games that we've seen
uh what's the message that the
challenger has sent across to the world
champion what i'm hearing not only in
the games but from jan himself is that
i'm not afraid i don't care that this is
a world championship i'm playing against
magnus carlsen that's the point of this
exercise so he somehow has blocked out
all the noise all the distractions any
question where we try to pull it out are
you afraid are you are you nervous if
you're uncomfortable now he's like i'm
playing chess i'm
nerves are gone that's done we're making
moves and i think that magnus now knows
that he faces a relaxed opponent a
determined opponent and that all jan and
his entire team is thinking about is
crushing him that's all they want they
want to win this match and yan right now
looks like joe cool magnus knows he's
got a fight on his hands
oh well there is only one thing to fight
for in this event and that is the world
championship title jan nabinachi making
his intention very clear playing
fearless chess another big battle ahead
of us back to you guys in the studio
thanks so much tanya oh it's so
interesting to hear from the people as
close to the action in dubai right now
magnus carlson in a deep think right now
thinking for 12 minutes on this next
move we are only move 16. okay he's
making move will the move come out what
do you think david how long will magnus
carlsen stay on this move yeah this is a
tricky one to call uh magnus now he's
been thinking for 12 minutes just by his
changing body language it shows he's not
quite ready to make a decision yet and
it is a big big moment because if he
doesn't find this pawn move maybe white
will use that square for his own pawn or
use it for his own night and
uh somehow it feels like black is going
to struggle for space struggle for
activity struggle for control if he
doesn't find it so um for me of course i
would be spending 30 40 minutes but i do
have a feeling magnus will also invest
quite a lot of time i wouldn't be
surprised if he thinks for another 10
minutes or so before uh either pushing
that pawn or maybe sliding his rook
across and oh here comes okay of course
he's played it
played it magnus carlsen has played his
pawn to e5 that means he's in
preparation
and is following some uh fantastic
calculations that he's probably made
with his team
yeah that's what we're speculating yes
he's following the analysis that i have
here on my computer that was studied in
october 27th
so uh okay that was last month and we
did see that magnus went into his memory
palace
and really and even now he's still just
trying to remember all the fine details
because if you remember the line that we
showed it did get pretty critical
because white was allowed to just open
up the center
yeah and uh it's unclear yet whether
magnus is still kind of following
something he's looked at before or
whether he just got there by process of
elimination or because he's just i mean
the best player in the world
he's finding these uh once you give them
kind of not necessarily only moves but
once you give them a narrow path they
normally find those best moves
but either way that's unclear but uh i
think it will become clear over the next
few moves and yeah i think there's also
danger in that last position that white
could have moved the knight to a5 so if
you played like bishop c8 uh something
like this uh that knight could have come
there which actually more i looked at it
is is looking quite scary so maybe a5 is
one of those moves you kind of have to
find otherwise you're just worse and
when you're the world champion you're
you'll probably find uh such moves
um
i mean it's a very tense position and
the thing i kind of like about these
positions is that you don't have nearly
well you don't have any pieces exchanged
so all the pieces remain on the board
and at some point the position could
just burst into flames so there's loads
of tension loads of stuff going on but
one moment it just comes open and all
the tactics start to occur so it's like
that slow build up and that big sort of
crescendo which we're going to see at
some point i'd imagine in this position
yeah and uh we have a question from
kumar rasinos
on twitter and there we saw that magnus
actually had a very very long sink as he
went into the tank
and uh what is the kind of etiquette for
you know janupomniacci is would he be
allowed to get up and see the board from
his opponent's side of
i am as far as i know you're allowed to
do that i mean you don't want to be
standing right next to their shoulder
kind of in their personal space
disturbing them but
i occasionally do that i just get up and
as long as my opponent isn't disturbed
then i can watch from a frog check it
out and maybe see what the opponent's
plans might be one of the most annoying
things i don't know about you guys but
you have your opponent and
they come and literally stand behind
your shoulder yeah so i was told this by
one coach that you you should go around
and look at the position from your
opponent's point of view so you get to
see their point of view on the position
but then if your opponent literally is
like his head over your shoulder
you can just feel their presence and
it's like no just go away and i know a
lot of players do this on purpose you
know these guys don't but if you're
playing in a tournament then
they certainly used some quite quite
outlandish tactics to try and put you
off you know and of course they wouldn't
be so none of the players are here right
now they wouldn't be allowed to sit in
the other one's chair right
now
i would love that
i'd love to see that in the world
championships just go around and sit in
their chair yeah and then the other just
swivel around baby just enjoy yourself
right yeah yeah
just admit it like sometimes your
position sucks you just want to sit on
the other yeah yeah just enjoy their
view for a second or two yeah well it is
a tense moment in the game magnus
carlsen has moved his form to a
you and pogba do in return he's not by
the board right now and as we mentioned
yesterday we do like to see those
faces so let's take a look at your
selfies
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much everyone for watching
and for sharing your selfies using the
hashtag c24live vienna pogniacci just
came back to the board will we see a
quick move from him now david i think a
quick move is very likely from yandere
pontiac maybe not over the next 30
seconds or minute but
this doesn't seem like the kind of
position where you invest 20 30 minutes
for me there's only one clear plan now
for white and that would be initiated by
moving the white dart squared bishop and
uh what do you guys think i only see one
sensible option here it's why you put
that bishop on that square to begin with
i mean why else
has two ideas as well if you go bishop
c3 has this idea of going queen d2 and
just winning that pawn but it has the
idea of opening the center which we
talked about
at some point something will come to
life and you can try to push with d4 as
i think you mentioned david
showing there on the board so bishop c3
looks very obvious here
i find a lot of these positions when
you're playing chess and again this is
something that people don't really
consider
it's not just who's better even if it's
by point one is whose position is easier
to play
even at this level which is incredibly
obviously the best level you can get if
your position is slightly easier to play
your moves are more natural you have
easier plans and that gives you some
kind of advantage and it seems to me
that white's position is it's more
natural to play i don't know if
obviously david you play at the highest
levels if that's something you you take
into account and you thank yourself as
well when you play
yeah now all the time it's for me it's
not the number one consideration when
choosing openings because objectively
everything's pretty much equal these
days uh there's no good or bad openings
is he about to play this move um but
yeah the key thing is just choosing
positions that the plans are
straightforward and it looks like he has
indeed brought his bishop to this square
as we predicted there's two ideas
pushing a pawn forward exploding things
open this would lead to complete chaos
if you place it next or as simon
mentioned just sliding the queen forward
one square for example if black moves
the bishop sliding it forward and
targeting this pawn uh you got to time
it correctly there might be consequences
to each decision but either way
uh i think simon's on point there this
was part of the plan it was a
straightforward move and that's why
napoli actually may be feeling slightly
more comfortable right now just because
there was no other
sensible way forward
and
yeah i'm just checking with ceci as well
and the top move is for the light
squared bishop to go back to its home
square and re-route itself so we might
see this is such a hard move to find
though bishop c8 i think right i mean i
think unless you've looked at it with a
computer yeah but i do think that magnus
is going to find it he's gonna fire the
kind of move like that because i've seen
him do this type of thing before and it
is quite common in these type of
positions your bishop is blunted he's
looking at a wall so move it to a better
diagonal yeah it's not a good diagonal
but that diagonal is completely blocked
as you imagine and it is slightly
typical but not in this exact position
where they've been open lines where
there's open diagonals okay uh
personally i think it would take me a
long long time to come up with this move
we should also explain the reasons
behind it uh this retreat firstly
because you might want to bring it to
this square and create an annoying pin
against the white knight and against the
white queen but if white for example
stops that move if white pushes the pawn
forward controlling the square the
bishop wants to move then you can bring
it to the center and challenge against
white's light squad bishop and this is
the spanish opening the royal affairs
the whole uh kind of heart and soul of
the opening is this white light squared
bishop it was bobby fisher's best kind
of favorite piece as well and if you can
kind of neutralize the light squad
bishops you might neutralize white's
advantage so um yeah a very logical move
once you stumble across it but not easy
to have on the radar
uh
it's not kind of human instinct okay
magnus frowning slightly there
and uh
i think maybe it comes back that white
has a slight easier position to play i
mean bishop c8 i'm sure he will find it
but he's going to take he's going to
spend a lot of time finding such moves
of this and jan but he always seems
quite confident yeah doesn't he he's
very hard to tell from his body language
because he's always getting up when he
plays move and he just has that extreme
confidence about him but sorry simon i'm
uh tanya is down and dubai was an
interesting report what's going on in
dubai tanya
kaiana we heard it from grandmaster
maurice ashley that both players playing
atypical positions like we've been
seeing them uh in game one and game two
quite unique structures on the board
pawn trades i've got with me a marshall
expert grandmaster hans neiman joining
us to take us through what exactly
happened now hans
in this position in front of us is where
magnus went into his first big thing
jan played knight d2 and then we saw
magnus hold his head
take a moment and pause what happened
here so you know some people might think
that this thing actually means he
doesn't know the position but i can
assure you magnus has looked at this
position and knows exactly what he's
doing um it's a common thing a lot of
top players do is
when
it's he's making a psychological
decision here he's choosing essentially
to go for the main line um which is
knight to a5
and after bishop a2 c5 knight f1 bishop
bishop c8 this is a fake show me
theoretical line something i've played
myself and he's probably thinking okay
if jan is going for this specifically
he's got some ideas and maybe this is
somewhere where magnus doesn't feel
comfortable going straight into the ants
operation so
then he's thinking to himself okay how
can i deviate um in this position
without sort of making giving too much
of an advantage so in this here
he's probably got maybe two or three
other alternative moves that he can play
to sort of surprise you on and i think
the surprise factor is extremely
important so he played rookie a um you
know a move that is definitely not the
main move um but it's the goal of this
move is to sort of say to to tian
okay you're not going to get the nade a5
mainline now show me what you've got um
so this was a really interesting
theoretical moment something i'm a
specialist i played a lot of games with
with the black pieces here and i can
assure you that if i know a lot about
this magnus knows 10 times more um so
although he might be thinking and you
might think oh
maybe he's got
maybe he's worried maybe he's unsure but
i can assure you that he is thinking
extremely psychologically and how he's
going to make his you know his next
decisions
i'm looking at magnus behind us on the
big screen right now and hans i have to
say that he doesn't look very
comfortable with what's going on so what
do you think is what is he thinking
right now so
i think there has i think he maybe
is regretting possibly not going for
knight a5 because knight a5 is sort of
the direct equalizer it's not completely
equal but if from my analysis and from
general top-level analysis if you take
it deep enough it's equalizing so
perhaps he's regretting that specific
decision and perhaps he's been just you
know annoyed that jan has
played so well and you know as you see
in the position currently this a5 pawn
um could be a long-term weakness and i
think that he's a little bit
uncomfortable and one thing that jan is
really impressed with is
i i when i look at his face and when i
see
how he's sitting i can just sort of tell
that he's not
he's comfortable like sitting he's at
the world chess championships i expected
honestly it's it's not easy to sit down
and and sit on that chair like you own
it and like you are meant to be here so
i think psychologically
magnus is realizing that jan is here to
play jan is here to fight and
you know this is going to be this is not
going to be easy
it is the world championship match so
it's not meant to be easy and definitely
big fights
have been happening and will continue to
happen hans what do you think about
magnus
showing his main prep against e4
going for e5 and always trying to get
the marshall
well yeah it's definitely sort of
in tune with the theme of the last match
against caruana as we saw with e4 c5 and
the semester cove being the main sort of
battleground
so
essentially i think magnus is saying
okay i'm willing to fight in the
marshall i'm willing to prove my
preparation and i'm willing to make this
to the general fighting ground so i
think that's really interesting it's an
opening i like a lot myself
and i've played a lot myself and i think
it's great and i think it's going to
create a lot of dynamic play creating
winnie signs winning chances for both
sides so i think this is really
interesting for the battleground um
and i honestly was surprising to me but
i think uh based on these first two
games the rest of the match could just
be you know
jan trying to find ideas in the marshall
very interesting and i can see on our
live board magnus has gone for the idea
of bishop c8 rerouting that bishop uh
what's your take on the current position
so i do like this idea with bishop c8
bishop b6 sort of the main
dynamic of this position even the
position we have on the board is that
the bishop on b7 just isn't great um
because the bishop on b7 the the entire
sort of premise of this position is
broken down into whether you can play d5
and the the structure and the premise
under which d5 is played now with this
d3 and a4 setup it's really sort of
targeted to prevent d5 which meaning the
bishop must reroute so i think with this
reacting the bishop i think he's
slightly worse but on on an objective
perspective he should be able to
equalize and play you know dynamic game
although jan definitely has an advantage
now
thank you so much hans for that
that we have a grand master hans neiman
with his take on the current position
yeah thank you so much tanya and hanson
super interesting han saying that
definitely there is an advantage for
janna pomnyacci right now it does look
that way if we trust the computers and
this type of position i'm quite inclined
to trust them because it's about to open
up it's about to get quite forcing and
dynamic and
magnus carson he did find the move we
should mention uh while they were having
the chat there black did find the move
that we were recommending quite an
important move rerouting that uh bishop
but if janupon actually plays the most
principled reply i think he will then uh
magnus still has some hard work to do a
lot of defense ahead
what do we think guys is white going to
push his central pawn forward push the
d-pawn explode things open
just like this might be the moment this
is i think if he does play it's a good
sign for yan because he he is an
aggressive player
and um we want to kind of see that
aggression at some point he's got to
play a move like that if he wants to win
this match he can't he can't sit there
and play long games which is something
magnus specializes in so i think d4
would be a very positive sign uh for his
team if he played it now because it's a
very positive move you're just trying to
open it up and of course your vancouver
you have some more information on this
position as well that pawn push was the
move that was studied in october and i
have an interesting story here because
um
on october the 20th someone looked at
porn takes porn
and
they analyzed after porn takes porn they
analyzed uh they actually just stopped
there so we don't have any more moose
but on october 27th
they turned around and looked at night
takes pawn as well
so this is on the cloud
definitely in the yeah this is in the
cloud database where you can look at
what people have been studying
can we know how far they studied maybe
because this looks like quite a forcing
variation after knight takes pawn
there's about to be trades of pieces for
the first time in the game it does
continue okay so it continued after
everything got swapped off
and uh there was a bit of indecision you
know bishop takes born or queen takes
born both lines were looked at
and uh in the end queen takes porn was
kind of looked a little bit more looks
like the uh most attacking look at these
bishops potentially still need some help
to get pieces out of the way for them
but
scary pieces yeah i think towards the
black king and then the line continues
do you want me to go yeah keep going
the lights the square bishop developed
to the e6 square that's right david and
then they looked at a very subtle move
actually stepping back with the queen
one square
okay interesting okay
could it be on a problem actually that
has studied this could be because the
line ends here
and then i here i can see that's a oh
seven oh hang on a second in november
26th that was a few days ago it was
revisited okay wow okay
crazy november 26th yeah november 26th
that was the day of the first game of
this match wow it feels like it might be
teaming up omni actually because
maybe they realized he wasn't getting
any anywhere with the way he played in
game one all right so maybe they were
trying to find a different way to play
in game three his next but wouldn't yan
be playing quickly he strikes me as a
kind of character we're talking about
these guys that might try to hide their
analysis or they try to scare their
opponent i think if jan had prepared
this a couple of days ago he'd be
banging out the booze with pure
confidence you know i don't i mean but
it is very strange timing that you've
got this here a couple of days ago
this position has been fine maybe magnus
before the game was uh because he didn't
know that it would be an h3 anti-marshal
and he was expecting this so maybe he's
kind of
yeah oh in those seven seven minutes
that he spent in the car
[Laughter]
maybe someone just logged on while they
were in the car
oh wow this is you called it david
modern chess oh it's crazy on the screen
right here it's like a spy thriller it's
like
who did this who did that who was it
yeah but we never get this actually
whenever they get this type of
information usually you know we're
always second guessing and we kind of
think oh what kind of novelties do the
seconds uh
up in their kitchen and here
someone by going on the cloud engine and
not analyzing privately has actually
given us a real look in into what
they've studied and it i think the dates
are making sure that i think it is going
to be someone from team magnus or team
nepo i think the team member who
accidentally made that information
public do you think the team member will
get in trouble for example if magnus if
it was one of his team one of his
coaches if he finds out that it was out
there on the cloud maybe he'll just be
like what were you doing why didn't you
click off that bell button
it's such high stakes i mean if if this
game goes in one side's favor then the
losing side might well blame their team
for maybe not being so thorough it's
amazing how chess preparation has has
moved on i mean like in my 40s and when
i was when i was learning chess you just
didn't use computers and now you're not
just using computers you're using cloud
computers
and you know what's it going to be next
and you've got all this information you
can save online supercomputers is
another another level of uh
analysis now d4 he's played it
and um
i i have to say if i you know i'd be a
little bit nervous if i was in team team
magnus now because
he could be a little bit worse the
position is opening up but it's also
i feel the kind of position that jan
enjoys playing he likes having the
initiative most of the pieces on the
board those bishops you pointed out
david are looking incredibly strong both
striking down towards black's king
and you've got to be careful here with
black you've got to be really careful i
mean if you compare the black bishops to
the white bishops right the white
bishops now that things are about to
become open they're staring down at the
black king both black bishops back on
their starting squares despite having
both moved a couple of times so yeah
definitely the stakes are higher for
magnus and do you think you guys
probably know magnus more than me his
body language do you think he is there
any way
you can tell from his body language
anything at all
would you say it doesn't look happy to
me but i i i guess it could just be his
normal concentrating look
i have a feeling he still
vaguely knows what's going on here and
right
i mean normally he's quite expressive
with his face okay there he kind of
shrugged and kind of um grimaced but um
yeah in general i think maybe he's
yeah he's about to make a move and he's
where's he
he's taken with a pawn yes ceci and uh
the computer were really indecisive you
know porn takes pawn knight takes porn
they should result in the same position
okay
um are we still
um
two days ago that's crazy wow yeah it's
unbelievable we're still in there 19.
yep
imagine if we end up will move 25 30.
so this is still analyzed so this was
literally so why this is so amazing is
that this was analyzed on on a cloud
server two days ago for the first time
ever
and um now we're seeing it and we're not
sure who who put it up but they maybe
could have put it up as private but they
put it up as public so someone's whoever
did that your job's on the line son
they're probably most worried more right
than anyone else why didn't i press the
private button but um it's fascinating
yeah isn't it fascinating as well that
it's hard to tell if it is
team carlson or team nepogniacci or some
random random random card out there and
you started this and you're not on their
team please tweet us definitely i wanna
get to know you we wanna call you yeah
hashtag c24 live
yeah if you are the culprit then get on
the show
so yeah and we're going to have you call
out the lottery numbers today as well
yes
and uh there we go napoli actually makes
a bit of a face and then takes back the
pawn with his knight okay so uh napoli
actually i can't it looks like just
having played him several times he made
a bit of a face but it feels like he's
trying to control his emotions and not
try to give too much away so so this is
this is still following everything yeah
queen takes then it was uh bishop e6
yeah i mean both
yeah and he will take with the queen
surely it's the most natural move right
yeah and now bishop e6 and you might as
well just tell us the whole game you've
anchor i'll just go
i'll go and have a cup of coffee you can
tell us how it ends
one of them studied this we think that
is quite clear for sure the other one
has seen
this that has been open out there and
has also studied it but privately okay
he just adjusted the piece
i adjust
wow
okay so
yeah i mean we i think we will find out
for sure over the next i've said this
before but we'll find out now uh over
the next couple of moves who knows the
position better
and i do think napoli actually just
judging by his body language maybe it's
him yeah very confident yeah
i mean just visually i i don't know how
what you think of anchoring david but
visually
it looks it looks nice and white um
without going deep analysis i mean the
pawn on a5 this week the bishops look
nice white is very nicely centralized i
mean okay it's not a concrete assessment
but visually if you had to glance on it
would you you surely take white here
yes
yes simple simple answer there as we
mentioned the two bishops they have the
potential to be strong the queen i mean
if you compare all the pieces the queen
is better than the black queen the two
bishops are better than their
counterparts and the white knight you
could argue it's right now more active
than black's knight and the rooks
may be better positioned uh four things
to open up if white can kind of pummel
through and just break with another pawn
push uh black will be attractive here he
goes bishop v6 quickly has he played it
he played that quickly
yeah wow
i'd love to hear the press conference
yeah afterwards just to know i hope they
are uh
if this is the case one of them has one
team has studied this openly
uh forgot to to press private button the
other team has seen this and is also in
that preparation how big of a scandal
would that be for the team for getting
to put this private definitely wouldn't
be ideal i mean in public magnus or
whoever it is will say oh it's it's
nothing it's fine it's fine but then in
private they will be having words
because if it's happened in this
variation it might have happened in
countless other openings oh wow
because you had this scandal um
obviously a couple of years ago well not
more than a couple years ago when
fabiano was playing against magnus's
world championships and
they they released this video
um
showing fabiano's computer and it was
showing a very deep position
on the computer and showing his
preparation they they showed this in a
video on youtube so someone had
literally led his preparation just being
shown on a public domain
and uh trough all over it yeah yeah it
didn't really make it very subtle like
fabi's preparation for the world
championships petrol variation or
something like that and it's like you
know so if magnus's team we're looking
at that it's like wow so these kind of
mistakes
you have to you have to be a bit crafty
or just careful don't you i think at the
moment so yeah and the thing is that was
a complete accident it was part of a
bigger shot they were just showing the
throwing the team's faces and then it
was just one corner someone had zoomed
in screenshotted and uh they found out
their information and it wasn't a bluff
that was actually his opening so that
was that so but then they they i think
they claimed it was a bluff so then
you've got to think where they're double
bluffing so it's like did they put that
information out they're never going to
play the petrol they're just throwing it
out there so or is it a triple bluff so
it's like um yeah and of course he did
he played the petrov in in nearly every
game so
it was just a mistake so there was talk
as well in 2016 when magnus played
karjakin of magnus hiring someone
especially to look after the cyber
security to make sure there were no
hacks make sure nobody could find out
that information make sure everything
was private
and uh yeah i'm sure both sides as well
they'll be very very aware of keeping
things uh
things under lock and key
yeah and uh okay meanwhile no problem
actually thinking we actually showed
this position a few minutes ago and we
thought that white's queen could just
step back one square to d3 and that
might be the most accurate move that's
not obvious that's really not obvious i
don't understand this queen d3 move
yeah sorry david i mean it's just
thinking it looks like it's going to get
hit by a knight um what would be the
reason for white to draw the queen back
one square
i think maybe two reasons for it as you
mentioned simon it's it's very
mysterious right now um this queen move
if he finds it i'll be amazed
or i'll be very impressed by his
preparation but
right now i'm trying to work out whether
white can actually grab this pawn on the
side of the board and i think the answer
is maybe not because after a move such
as this one pushing the pawn forward
attacking the queen black will have some
counter play and suddenly the queen's
eye line is opened up towards this white
knight and even if black even if white
doesn't lose any any material here the
queen is forced back to a bad square
just to protect her knight and suddenly
there will be trades and for example
this central pawn will drop to the black
knight i think black could just take it
immediately also this pawn will drop at
some point so i don't think white can
capture this pawn on the side of the
board yet and maybe if you drop back the
queen
maybe you're threatening this if black
just kind of does nothing just a random
move then maybe you can get away with
taking this pawn at some point you also
maybe indirectly defend your bishop you
do step out of the eye line of black's
porn
there won't be any tempo gaining or time
gaining threats against the white queen
so it's very very deep
i
doubt i'd find this move to be honest i
doubt i'd play it
i would be very tempted to be looking at
direct options or maybe just securing
some breathing space for the white king
later on i would have thought around
here this would be a very good
indication of uh
their preparation i mean queen d3
it doesn't look like a human move to me
i mean it obviously point out it has
great sense to get out of the move c5
and also at this level they can find
moves like this but there are a lot of
other very natural moves here as well
also this would encourage black to just
retreat the night i think you mentioned
this idea earlier simon of bringing the
knight forward and starting to hit the
white queen so it's not entirely clear
it's actually safer on this square but i
i can tell you the move that was
analyzed after the queen dropped back to
d3 is actually not retreating the knight
because that looks very natural it's
actually to blast open the center
already with
pawn pushing to d5 and so the whole idea
is again it's a pawn sacrifice which
really fits in with magnus's whole
strategy it appears from games one and
two sacrifice the pawn get initiative so
bishop takes knight was the main line
and after queen takes bishop pawn takes
pawn the bishop comes and attacks the
queen
and the analysis just stop there okay so
this is finally the end of the line yeah
wow that's that's good i mean this
actually kind of sacrifice reminds me of
game one where where magnus will get the
two bishops he's a pawn down but he has
clear compensation uh with space and the
bishops so
this is their strategy just lose the
pawn get the two bishops and you're
happy so
um magnus if we look back in game one he
sacrificed to pawn game two yesterday he
sacrificed the pawn maybe he'll go for
this and sacrifice another third time in
a row yeah so let's see so well i mean i
don't think queen d3 will be played
is it is this well we could do a
prediction here but i don't i don't know
about this queen d3 maybe later on but
what else should you play here
what else that's the big question do you
throw pawns forward at the risk of
opening up your king it doesn't feel
like you're ready for that no uh it
feels like it could backfire i mean i'd
love to just i'd love to play this f4
move it's a very attractive move but
this this movie vanco mentioned d5 at
some point just seems like a great way
uh and then the white later on as we can
see later yeah it does doesn't seem to
work but
um
i'd love to try to attack here at white
surprise surprise
you know so well on that subject um yeah
i can just see that everyone you know
now upon seeing this game has gone crazy
and is actually checking out what it
should be playing and there's a whole
load of moves that people are looking at
and
they're looking at attacking like simon
says there's someone who's suggesting
actually doing a rover which is when the
rook lifts up the board
and then swings the croc
to attack the king
and so someone is looking at moving up
the rook to the third rank and
getting ready for an attack there other
people have been looking at just uh
relocating the rooks that's sitting on
the sea one square and moving it to the
d1 square other people are looking at
actually just retreating the light
squared bishop so i can just see now
there are 21 moves so is this basically
as we've been commentating yeah people
are sort of realizing that it's on the
cloud they're going on the cloud they're
putting their own movies they're just
going on to a database and they're just
uh
consciously or unconsciously they might
they might have this button which says
let's check and if you have that let's
check function on what is going on the
cloud and it's checking up and against
uh the analysis and uh well here we go
now it's hard to tell whether it's one
of the two players seconds or whether
it's just some random viewer yeah
did the random viewer admit to it yet do
we have um
well you know we have
mr hot tub on twitter said yeah yeah it
was me
the first time
it's the hot tub
so his name is the hot tub mr hot tub
yeah on his birth certificate that's his
name yeah yeah
just call me the hot tub baby
so
i i really like this rookie free i mean
i think it's a bit a bit early but this
is just the kind of move
that if you had time to get the rook to
g3 you'd very much like to play with
those bishops you kind of need to have
when you're attacking like this we're
not really attacking but in order to
start an attack you need to get as much
ammunition
around towards your opponent's king it's
all about timing as you discuss so
swinging the rook over the rover rook
over that's the one i call it the rook
swinger
swinger um the rook lift the rook lifter
one of these moves i mean it seems like
a nice idea but maybe it's too slow rook
to g3 at least would start we'll have a
very nasty threat behind it yeah so in
the current position that's very
tempting but it does take one two years
and a lot of bases maybe magnus would be
able to break out in the center as we
showed definitely there would be some
big consequences here
so uh yeah critical moment actually when
i commentated with magnus on the
candidates uh on the candidates
tournament he loved these rook lifts
every position he was just suggesting
these rook swings these rovers
if he studied this before magnus for
sure this would have been on his radar
for his opponent and he would have been
checking out what to do there
i mean his favorite maneuvers
i mean is there any way i guess white
can
can do something like knight d2 and just
try to
take the sting out to d5 um if we see a
trade again you attack this pawn yeah
isolated pawn my my idea is to try to
meet d5 seems to be like a key idea that
that black's got in these positions if
black can play d5 black's freeing the
position up and i i want to try to meet
this move with with e5 you know in in in
most structures if i can i mean again
you've got c5 moves so it gets
incredibly complicated and i don't
really like moving my pieces backwards
but
it's uh it's an idea i suppose but a bit
passive bit passive yeah it's not clear
who this favors actually because black
does have two very strong pawns now and
even if black's forced to retreat as
well suddenly there's threats in the
position of black marching forward
talking about backward moves i do i also
have to point out another suggestion
that was made by ceci the
the computer that follows magnus's games
and the top choice is actually
retweeting the queen second choice and
this one you know if napoleon plays this
move we know that he's it's him who's
been studying this so this one is
actually no
one step further
okay
if he plays bishop d1 then
why is that so strange uh i mean you
never see a retreating move like that
also you're taught never to disconnect
your rooks rooks are best when they're
connected um i mean also what is the
bishop doing here it looks like it's
hitting thin air
i still don't understand
and sometimes computers just don't
understand the position like for
instance if you'd put um game one that
magnus and the pomona actually played
against each other um if you put the
position that they got in the middle
game the computers didn't really know
what to do they would say yeah yeah yeah
i own a white is better but then we just
shuffle shuffle shuffle shuffle
nothing no plans no nothing and uh it's
just weird yeah that's the big problem i
found from studying with computers
sometimes six different moves will lead
to an equal position they'll say
everything is 0.0 but of course four of
those moves make sense to a human two of
them
absolutely no logic behind it but it
doesn't lose or it doesn't worsen the
position okay so that looks like the
type of move which doesn't worsen the
position but probably doesn't improve it
either and for a human you always want
to improve things or you always want a
kind of logical plan you don't want just
a bunch of random kind of
lucky dip type of moves so so jan's
definitely not going to move his bishop
back to the background i think if he
does that i will wear that teddy tubby
uniform okay yes
maybe maybe
oh my god what did i just say on that
note
that note did i just guys that i think
i'm going to have to launch the guest
the move because i want to see simon in
a teletubby costume
and it's up to you guys the viewers at
home now to choose the movie what is the
anna pommy actually going to play if he
plays bishop d1 but okay it's that
moment guys come on let's do it
[Music]
awesome stuff david you launched guess
the move in this position and that means
the viewers they now have to guess to
move on twitter yup and we don't know
how much time you have to remember so
message us using the hashtag c24 live
what move do you think janna pomegi is
going to play he's already been spending
12 minutes he could make a move in the
next minute or two he could make a move
in the next 20 minutes but message us
your thoughts
is he going to play a move that simon
thinks he won't i'm going to end up in a
teletubby costume oh i hope so
it's not actually going to play maybe a
more sensible move wow
there's going to be a prize there is
going to be a prize and it is one year's
membership of g's chess which is the
first ever website where you can just
put up a search a chess position on a
chess database and it can search through
these test databases chess articles
chesterball short and sweet and also
youtube so it's an awesome prize it's
tremendous resource at your fingertips
so please tweet your answer using the
hashtag c24 live and i will be picking
the winner it's always fun yes
all right well you still have time clock
is still ticking for you on the
pognyacci how many options
realistically does he have here uh
that's the thing many okay we've
suggested maybe three or four options we
showed them on the board a moment ago um
i think the bishop option is the least
likely of those but for example stepping
the white queen back one square pushing
some of the white pawns lifting up the
white rook which one appeals to you
yes no yeah and remember bishop d one
means uh simon gets to where the pinky
i'm sure the bet was that if i if if
bishop d one's played okay i'll go tinky
winky whatever
la la just give me the whole bloody i
don't care but if bishop d1 is not
played i'm sure david said he has to
wear it
i'm sure there's a winning side to the
event
no
i don't think he says oh okay
i'm getting a little bit
i mean i think
oh dear all right well you guys thirteen
fourteen minutes now before jana put my
in this move so you still have time to
make your predictions okay his hands was
raised and still thinking he's not sure
himself he's undecided and actually i
think this is the longest he's spent at
the board thinking since the beginning
of game one since very early in game one
so uh yeah right now it's
it's unclear
napolite if he retreats his queen we're
gonna head down towards that position we
showed earlier black sacrificing a pawn
if he lifts up his rook he's gonna try
and attack he's gonna go towards that
black king it's a stylistic option now
for nepogiacci all right what will it be
on the prognachi in this situation
magnus carlsen has left the board so
he's kind of following jana pognac's
strategy here to stay away from the
board as much as possible maybe yeah
mind games mind games yeah
definitely
all right
well
what will you do yana pomination will
you give us a tinky winky in the studio
probably not praise please yeah
he's been working with super computers
right there was a university in moscow
that that has a super strong computer
that he has been working with so i mean
is there slight chances or is is it
simply a bad move
it's not bad move definitely if the
computer suggests it
and also i've noticed the more i work
with computers the more kind of
concrete my thinking becomes i start
calculating more i'm more direct maybe
and
i start getting kind of infected with
these type of computer type ideas and
maybe that will happen for napoli
actually that type of move though
unless he studied it before unless he's
looked at this position um it's just
incredibly hard to have when your
candidate moves normally chess players
top chess players i think this was
mooted by kotov at one point in a book
called think like a grand master and he
talked about candidate moves you have
three or four on your radar you just
compare the three or four moves against
each other you look down the line you
evaluate and then you'd pick one
it's going to be very hard for napoleon
even if he's looking at four or five
different moves to somehow take a step
back and think okay i'm going to retract
my bishop i know they have these
microphones now which are quite
interesting at the end of the game yeah
they turn these microphones on so you
can hear what they're saying like oh
you know but um i just hope that one way
microphones because you know you might
have heard us in the studio and he's
like i'm just going to play bishop
i just want to see him wearing that suit
that's it i don't care about the world
championships i'm going bishop d1
um but that was quite interesting like
so yesterday and they had these they had
these microphones where at the end of
the game you could hear the players chat
to each other straight away afterwards
and i again i find it
quite peculiar that
the players do chat to each other so
much because it is the world
championships definitely it's so intense
and there it's like a war on the
chessboard and they're fighting for this
huge title yeah and you know dramatic
stuff happens in the game and the game
is over ah what did you think about that
move oh it was like just friendly it
smells actually yeah i was chatting to
ivanka earlier and we thought that i
mean the course of that conversation as
well it felt like napoli actually was
trying to take the dominant role he was
saying okay i saw this and this and this
and this and magnus was just saying oh
yes oh yeah oh yeah and it's very rare
to see that normally magnus is the one
who sees more or who kind of is more
confident about his evaluations but upon
actually yesterday he saw a lot clearly
from that conversation they had together
so maybe it was it sounded like a nice
conversation but maybe it was part of
the tactics for janna pomnyacci not the
yeah i mean there's been some famous
cases i think of like
people well often analyze their games
afterwards this is a very normal thing
to do if you're playing in a tournament
you finish the game you go into the
analysis room to have a look at your
look your games and i heard a story i
don't know if it's true that the
ex-world champion karpov um when he
analyzed the top players in the analysis
room he he would
play awfully you know he would do it on
purpose he'd analyze ridiculous moves
like you know where this is obviously
before his world champion and the guys
are playing was like how did i lose to
this idiot you know how could i lose to
him and next time they just think i'm
going to crush him and of course he
beats him again so
again someone told me this really don't
know if it's true but a lot of people
also try to be very dominant in united
states and they try to own the person
yeah um and this hack this is really
annoying i hate it when you try to
suggest moving they're like no
no no you can't who the hell are you you
know god oh god um but they do so
there's lots of different mind games
going on after the game even after the
game yeah yeah even yes it just never
stops no i mean you get people who you
know you've beaten and then they act
exactly like simon says and uh when i'm
in that situation i normally go
take it the point is yours
because i won the real point exactly and
uh yeah sometimes you get uh
actually sometimes it's surprising how
many players are just playing on
instincts you know i once analyzed with
a very top player and i was very
surprised you know he didn't say to me i
looked at this this isn't that and i
because that's what i was expecting he
said
no he hadn't seen that move oh i was
like everything i showed he said no he
hadn't calculated that his instincts
were actually refined by the pattern
recognition wow that was really
insightful actually yeah and uh just to
see how selectively his brain had worked
yeah that's the case as well the first
time i ever analyzed with michael adams
who was the english number one for 20
odd years uh yeah i was just shocked by
how open-minded he was when i suggested
something he's like oh actually yeah
that's really interesting i didn't
really consider that or he'd say okay
this position maybe it's good for white
not sure it's about the practical um
it's about the practical considerations
but uh yeah there's also as simon says
there's one
guy famous on the english test scene who
he's actually several hundred points
lower rated than some of his opponents
but he's always he thinks he knows
better
i i know exactly who you're talking
about
i'm not gonna mention any names but he's
he's not he's let's just say he's not a
grand master but he thinks he's
like 200 you know points better than
magnus you know so you know you're very
confident in the analysis
basically there's a confident and then
this is something else you know so do
you know who we mean yeah of course i
don't okay there we go there's this i
actually saw was actually in hastings uh
chess congress which is an amazing
tournament and a lot of history behind
it but he was analyzing with the swiss
version of himself
no meeting of mines whatsoever you know
one of us going i'm absolutely winning
the other no
you're wrong
i was just like this i'm going to grab
myself a bucket of popcorn
get the phone out start recording it so
yeah
[Laughter]
oh my god
you're very naughty with your phone
don't you have to say recording things
you know i'm just waiting one day you
know i can tell my story and you should
start the chess gossip girl uh column
yeah thinking about this ooh bring us
all the gossip from the chess world one
day yeah
it is
i bet there would be a lot of gossip in
the chess world because it's it's quite
a small
environment worldwide right you you
would know most of the top chess players
you hang out at big tournaments we do
yeah yeah that
yes is the answer i think yeah
it was fill several volumes of books
and um yeah maybe we should just keep it
there yeah
there's so many chess books on chess
analysis and chess games and chess
openings give us the next book on chess
gossip yeah maybe tweet us if you like
that idea or if you know any uh if you
could come up with any good titles oh
obviously there was a good um history
book actually and it was published by
new and chess and uh it was called
timmins titans and i have to say he
gives a no-holds-barred uh kind of uh
he just tells the story of the top
players and he tells stories that you
know were known in the chess world but
he's the kind of the first one in my
opinion to kind of put it out there on
print
everywhere you start to look at the
world champions in different lights and
see them as quite human yeah
yeah going through the world champions
that we are doing also simon it becomes
clear that many of them were
i heard the word womanizers womenizers
you know they were married a bunch of
times and just you know played chess yep
but with girls yeah yeah but i think uh
yeah yeah i mean i think we're looking
at uh alec later yeah i think he was
married five times did we say something
like that trying to check my research
yeah it was yeah four or five times so
it's yeah quite a lot of times yeah
yes wondering how we got on this topic
yeah we talked about chess analysis one
moment
computers and how and how it's uh
developing the game and then suddenly
gossip
yes gossip yeah well janna bonnier is
still thinking for 22 minutes now that's
a long thing even in classical chess
definitely a long thing and
characteristic as well yeah yeah and uh
before we do a deep five maybe again in
this position uh mel griffin has a
question
and he asks us so or she asks us how
long do you suggest one takes to study
at classical game
oh that's a very good point actually um
in the past i always used to say however
long the game lasted you should spend
the same amount of time studying a game
but if you play a seven-hour game nobody
wants to sit there for seven hours
studying so um i would always recommend
going through the game on a board first
maybe actually especially analyzing with
your opponent or analyzing with some
friends so you get some other opinions
and then afterwards only then you go and
check maybe with the computer to see uh
just use the computer as a blunder
checker don't necessarily
kind of rely 100 on the computer's
evaluation
often your move is nearly as good or
just good enough anyway um but uh yeah i
in the past i used to spend a lot of
time analyzing my games maybe an hour or
so on each game but these days i've
become slightly lazier just clicking
some computers and i find i left
definitely learnt more when i was
putting it on a board and analyzing with
others was it more important with the
team aspect before computers to analyze
games you would need someone to spar
with someone to talk to about the game i
mean yeah you had the soviets scored a
chess as well i mean we're going to come
to botfinic later on who was a very
famous world champion and really helped
the russians become so strong and
i think his main advice was analyzing
your games he said he could one of your
games you could take a week analyzing so
literally a week to look at every single
aspect and i think that's
one thing they did a lot to find all the
weaknesses all the strengths and their
plays so i don't think you can really go
wrong with analyzing your games but i
think you can if you're using a computer
because again
it's you know you've got to understand
the why why are you doing things and the
computer doesn't tell you that why and i
think that when bodz finnick was doing
it he was trying to understand why
you're playing this why are you doing
this what should you be doing it's all
the whys basically why you know that's
that's to well worth bearing in mind i
think yeah for analyzing computers
nowadays they're so good but they only
spit out moves and numbers yeah it's all
about the questions why and actually
bought vinnic for example kasparov
learnt from the botvinnik school of
chess
i think it's part of their practice they
would show their games to their
colleagues and then
kind of discuss their thoughts analyze
them afterwards and uh
you know what what is your opinion on
computers and how they're developing the
game or changing its nature because we
have a tweet from bruno who says and if
this is true stuff so far is just a
battle of memorization much like fisher
said opening theory
ruining chess having mixed feelings
about this
possibly i mean if you're talking about
the very elite level these 2 800 players
i mean the top
top five in the world for them often it
is a battle of memory but also i mean
it's a battle of homework it's like any
sport you do your preparation you get
physically in the zone you study your
opponents you try and look for these
tiny one percent margins
i think that's just the way the world is
going and if we embrace it computers
have taught us so many new ideas they i
mean we're just as creative now i feel
um as we were in the past with creative
computers showing us these long-term
sacrifices and
um i think if we embrace it then there's
a lot of positives of course take some
of the romantic nature some of the
mystery out of the game but
yeah that's just the modern world yeah
if i mean if you had a choice would you
go back to the the days of
pre-computer or would you yes
oh definitely i mean but i wouldn't be
sitting here broadcasting so so there
are positives but i i i really prefer it
preferred it for computers personally
because uh
the memorization thing is uh well i'm
too old to do that now anyway but it's
uh the imagination i think is also you
can just refute sacrifices
by putting it on your computer for 10
seconds which is which is a real pity is
that why fish random is such a
you know it's getting more and more
popular this variant where the pieces
are placed randomly in the starting
position yeah
do you think that's going to get
increasingly popular i think at some
point that's the way maybe things are
heading um at least official random it's
more about general understanding and
calculation and talent as well i had an
interesting conversation with aryan
terry the norwegian number two
about these things and he told me that i
value talent too highly and actually
computers they help people who like to
work hard and that's just as valid yeah
i mean not everybody is born with uh an
ability like magnus to memorize
everything and uh it kind of levels the
playing field of course he's still the
best because he uses those tools but if
magnus didn't he couldn't rely just on
his talent i guess it's also a talent to
work hard exactly and this is something
that we're finding out to work hard and
to be you know very religious and you're
you're learning it is a real skill and
that's what you have to do yeah i mean
it's it's important even things like
memorization you know it is a talent to
kind of
go and research memorization and to
start learning the techniques to improve
that you don't necessarily have to kind
of fix yourself in the whole idea hey
i'm bad at memory i'm too old for that
you can actually go well let's let's try
and do something about it you don't have
to be at that level all the time
so
yeah i've been reading a lot of carol
dweck
fix my mindset growth mindset yeah well
this is all very relevant when we will
be talking about alkyne later on simon
coming after capablanca the big genius
the natural talent and then alekhine
maybe known for more
studying doing the work
yeah i mean you know
i think each world champion we've had
has had their kind of distinctive thing
that they've brought to to the game even
if it's very subtle and uh um well we're
going to discuss this later but kappa
blanco you could say is more um i would
say more magnus-like very natural player
he played very quickly and alekhine was
obviously a very natural you could say
genius as well but he he he did more
work i feel to to develop the game he
did more opening work and
you know even if you've got the best
talent it's much more important to have
a good work effort than the most talent
in the world you can see
very talented players and it's very hard
to judge talent as well how do you
actually judge talent um there was some
controversy recently wasn't there where
one of the seconds of a recent challenge
in the world championships
basically said there was many more other
players in this this contender who was
more talented than him
um i don't know if i should mention the
name but it's out there anyway um and
that that was
yeah it was a bit strange but um yeah
hmm
all right well you're on the publicity
30 minutes now almost spent on this move
it is uh guest move time so you guys can
still keep your suggestions coming in on
hashtag c24 live i just moved yeah i've
been sitting over 10 minutes fearing
bishop d1 should we remind them about
yeah what possibilities we're looking at
okay that's good
yeah so there are a few main
possibilities and just to recap the main
moves that we were discussing that we
were showing earlier
we were discussing for example white's
queen stepping back one square
white rook sliding across
for example this one is actually the top
computer suggestion move we've heard uh
from rebecca and just as this happens
he's made a move
simon it's not it's not teletubbies
get in there
it's the opposite it's harry harry harry
little harry i received you again he
does yeah good up good on you harry
thank you it wasn't the bishop retreat
that would have got simon dressing up
for us live on the show
just a pawn push it is just a pawn bush
but this was an idea that
hardly anyone thought of in fact i
mentioned it several times earlier
sorry
um i mean i never really went into
detail on the board but i just said it's
so natural just push your pawn create
some squares for your king so now
there's no background checkmate the king
does have some breathing space and i
guess also it stops the black knight
ever jumping forward
okay so logical but slow i kind of i
mentioned it just because it was on my
radar it's like first instinct but i
dismissed it because it just looks like
it doesn't suit the nature of the
position and
we mentioned this as black's
pretty much automatic reply in every
scenario and can he play d5 here i mean
if you commission i guess if you can
place d5 or c5 and d5
you might just equalize at least
equalize immediately
sorry uh in this position you mentioned
c5 as well as well as this pawn pushing
you could attack the white queen and
then push forward with your pawn yeah
something like this i mean this looks
i don't know i
again like a good option for for magnus
i would have thought yeah some
calculation i guess needs to be done
here bishop takes knight for example
could arrive and uh if the queen takes
now white would be a pawn up and maybe
this pawn isn't so greatly placed here
white can push forward but then again
for example after white's bishop takes
this knight i could consider taking the
white knight
and complete chaos yeah but uh
i mean some tactics you have to
calculate queen takes queen you have to
calculate bishop takes queen so much to
work out here so napoli actually just
spent 30 minutes on one move i
i'm pretty sure we'll see magnus spend a
lot of time as well maybe not 30 minutes
but he'll spend a lot of time working
out to push this pawn hit the queen
personally i think this one's the most
attractive pushing immediately
and after a trade maybe trying to
capture with the knight trying to take
this bishop trying to obtain the bishop
pair but then again we have to work out
what happens if white gets greedy and
snaps off a pawn
i mean so many variations actually yeah
it's constantly heating up it's kind of
coming to life now isn't it the position
of this is again what happens i'm sure
magnus would really want to push this
pawn to d5 and
i mean magnus plays a lot of subtle
chess you could say often but if he gets
an opportunity to go active he will take
it and things could really come to life
after after this pawn pushes the d5
um
so getting interesting yeah i think
those are the two main candidate moves
pushing this pawn opening things up
because black is very passive you can't
just sit the back and kind of uh
just do nothing forever or pushing this
pawn forward hitting the white queen you
can maybe make an argument for the black
knight dropping back as well re-routing
it this way to harass white's bishops
but either way i would be shocked
actually if we didn't see one of those
three moves from magnus especially this
one right now
well we did have the guests to move on
the previous move did anyone guess the
right move
the uh porn moving page three
and the winner of one year's membership
to g chess well that is axel armor
congratulations you are our winner you
correctly guessed that napolita you
would play h3 and you even gave it a
double x-clap
good good thinking i don't know i don't
know if that answer should count because
it's not really a double x fan
i mean he got it we went a little bit
overboard there to say he doesn't get
any g chess stuff try again
simon one exclamation mark
maybe maybe maybe we could push for that
so it's pushing harry the age one okay
maybe you should explain that with
exclamation points in in notation what
does that mean yeah so when players
write down moves um when you see chess
games kind of notated in magazines for
example in newspapers uh an exclamation
mark signifies a good move a strong move
uh or maybe a move that's not uh not
expected as well double exclamation mark
is just a genius oh wow those are quite
rare uh you want to write a queen
sacrifice stuff like that exactly for
the really really genius moves how about
blunders are there what would they look
like question mark
of course and the type of move that i
play quite often double question mark
for the
not biggest the truth
he's this british sense of humor i'm too
modest too modest way too honest david
doesn't make a double exclamation mark
i wish i wish he didn't make a double
explanation
okay
sorry david no that's okay and
occasionally you see a bit of a mix you
see exclamation mark then a question
mark that means interesting
um and if you see it the other way
around question mark then an exclamation
mark it means dubious a bit of a dodgy
one not bad but dodgy okay i can
remember the first time i played david
and
i it's interesting cause we're talking
about time control and i didn't realize
it's it's a bit different to uh the
standard time control in internationals
now where they're not getting increments
so normally in uh nearly every chess
tournament played you make a move and
you get a bit of time added to your
clock and uh i think it was a rhonian uh
world leading player who said yes dada
he felt maybe uh magnus is a little bit
uncomfortable with this with his format
which is the old format you don't get
added time so if they do get short time
you can hustle your opponent and this is
the way it used to be for the first 20
years of my life and i remember i i was
playing the iron man competition i was
playing a young a young kid
went to the board this young kid
you know
nice kid very well-mannered
he was sitting there and i was playing
him and
you know i've heard he's a real talent
you know be careful of this kid but i'll
be all right you know wheel out the
english um english opening and we play
very we play a very long game and this
kid
unbelievable the time would get down to
one second and i'd be looking at the
clock obviously he's got one second left
and then very calmly just go
and play a move and then get another
extra 30 seconds like oh come on man
next move
five four three two one i'll be like
this went on for about 40 moves and i
wasn't used to his time trying i thought
what i just thought he's got to lose on
time at some point
he ended up crushing me
i ended up crying
this kid was running around happy done
about running around and of course it
was this guy sitting next to me david
howe so he he used to like playing with
fire yeah
even when he was a kid which is quite
funny fantastic david howell okay we
have to uh go down to dubai because
tanya has a bunch of interesting guests
around the venue where the players are
sitting
thanks kaya i am outside the venue now
those are some fascinating stories we
see the challenge and the world champion
the current world champion
fighted out for the world championship
match we know yanna pumnachi and magnus
carlson two of the best players on the
planet for just how strong they are at
the game they come across as these
beasts these monsters over the
chessboard but there's a human side to
these two players and i am very pleased
to look into that side to get more
insights into that i've got a very
special guest with me and it is
grandmaster sergey yanovsky he's a long
time guide trainer
friend to janna pumnyachi he's been in
his team he's a manager now thank you so
much for joining us sergey
thank you yes really i started to work
with yanden he was 10 years old
and
when we started working jan
was the european champion among kids
three years in a row it was 2000 2001
2002
and in the 2002 he made the golden uh
double
and also he won the world championship
and in this championship he tied the
first place with magnus carlsen
but
according
to the special
rates he was the first and magnus was
the second
and i just remember
that after this
the end of the championship
uh next morning i met
magnus and his father uh henrik at the
tennis court and i was very pleased that
henrikh and magnus
congratulated me very warm
manna so i i was very pleased with the
gentleman's style of behavior
because i was a little bit worrying that
they're very disappointed that
they tied the first place but
they were not lucky and jan is the first
so
that was very
very nice exp impression
very long ago 19 years ago but still i
remember this day very well that is
incredible to hear now you have known
yan throughout his career
seeing him now fight for the world
championship match uh starting from
winning the european youth beating
magnus carlsen there as well what is the
feeling of seeing him fight it out in on
this stage
i always say that the feeling is that
sometimes
our dreams come true yes of course then
he was a little boy and then he saw
the awarding ceremonies at the very big
tournament
jan was very ambitious and he said one
day i will be on the stage and i will be
the first and now this dream come true
he is fighting the world championship
title i'm very glad and you know and
really happy that it's really
now
that
that's really really nice to hear now
the thing is that you know sergey we
often see when we think about yan we
know we speak of speed we speak of how
dangerous and aggressive his chat style
is
but there's always this human side to
all these players
and is there something that you know the
chess world doesn't know or something
that
that surprises you sometimes in real
life when you feel like all right jan
has this side of his personality as well
because the napo nyachi that we know is
an absolute beast on the chessboard
yes of course
very often
the
player expressed his character in his
chess games
but i will say that of course jan is a
real fighter yes he is very ambitious
he never thinks about the draw he tries
to fight for the victory till the very
very end of the game
but
in the
of course in the real life he's not such
a monster
he is very intelligent person
and he is very caring to the person who
are near him
and so i will say that he
managed to
have different features in his character
and he may be
very soft and gelatin from one hand and
a real fighter from the other hand
incredible and sergey what do you think
you've known yan for so many years
what is what are the qualities that he
has that
that separate him from his colleagues
i will say that to my mind one yan is
one of the most talented chess players
in the world
and
in general it is my own opinion but i
think that
in his generation he is the most
talented
to my mind he's even more talented that
magnus but the thing that magnus is a
very
stable person with very stable nerve
system
and very good
physical conditions
so i think
that the harmony of all these features
gives
magnus the advantage that's why he is
the first for so many years
but the specific chess talent to my mind
is the most bright
for jan it is he is the most bright
chess player the specific chess talent
is the most most
yes most talented person and the most
bright chess talent in the world that's
my own opinion of course i don't insist
but
i will just share this opinion with you
and tommy said
when jan was growing up you were his
chief trainer
what is
your role now in timian napogniachi
now i just
i will say the coordination of all
efforts
and just the organizational role first
of all
just the role of the chief of the
delegation it is necessary to coordinate
everything many
things and it was started from the
choosing of the place where we live
during the tournament and everything all
physical
training during the match before the
match so very many
different
problems which is necessary to
face every day and to solve these
problems every day also and it's so
important for these players to have
someone around them who they've known
for a long time who give them these
positive feelings so of course it means
a lot to yan to have you with him here
as well thank you very much i hope to
help him and i do my best in this
direction and my final question to you
sergey like you mentioned you've known
yan for years you've worked with him
when he won the european under 10 and 12
titles
similarly you've known you've seen
magnus grow up as well because he and
yan have been friends uh they've been
playing together in these youth
championships
what is your opinion on magnus carlsen
i will say that i have very positive
opinion about him he is a real fighter
but i think he is a nice person and he
is very friendly to his colleagues
and i will say that i think he is a very
good example of the real champion
and i think that
he is very popular among his colleagues
and also i
think it is very important that he
organizes a lot of tournament now during
pandemia and it helps
a lot
of his colleagues to make some profit
then
normal tournaments are out because of
this
lockdowns and all these so i think he
also cares about chess in general about
the development of chess so i'm a very
high opinion about him
thank you thank you so much again for
sharing your insights and impressions on
the players
wow sergey yanovsky giving us the human
side of the two of the best players on
the planet
thank you so much tanya it's so
interesting to hear from one of the
person's closest to yana pomnyacci in
dubai and now we're going to keep
talking about world champions we've
reached the fourth one and that is
alexander alekhine uh became world
champion in 1927 overtaking the title
from the genius capablanca and i heard
simon that he's maybe a little bit of an
opposition to capablanca what was the
style of
uh well alec is certainly one of the
strongest world champions and he did a
lot of good things to chess but his uh
his style can be uh defined as very
dynamic
um he had very good positional
foundations so he tried to always like
previous people like steinitz the first
world champion start attacks from
position of strengths but he'd also be a
very very aggressive player at times
very tactical player so he's kind of an
all-rounded player but he's a real
believer in the center he loves
attacking from the center if you look at
his games a lot of people have learned
how to play just by understanding his
feeling of the center of the board gain
the center and once you gain the center
it's like a battlefield if you control
the battlefield the center of the
battlefield you can attack your
opponent's king so he did these kind of
he brought these things to chess he
showed his games he was uh he was very
he had some very nice opening theory
things so he brought a lot of opening
ideas as well and uh yeah he's very
highly respected uh even nowadays by his
his peers all right well magnus carlsen
is here fan he's a massive fan
apparently yeah yeah i mean magnus
really knows his chess history um i
think a lot of the younger guys who are
so keen on memorizing their opening
moves they forget about the chess
history but magnus certainly does and i
think just talking we can see that a
move has been played and that is a
really surprising move we'll come back
to that a little bit later but magnus
just playing c6 there and that's a move
i think
we didn't expect uh over on the panel
but we'll be back there very very
shortly anyway let's check in with david
are you surprised david yes i'm
surprised i'm also impressed just by
magnus carlsen's patience we were
talking earlier simon about uh just
maybe this being the moment to press
forward to neutralize white to take
direct action but no magnus just
maintaining the status quo pushing upon
controlling some squares and also maybe
just the black queen now in helping to
protect black's isolated pawn over there
on a5 so sensible we'll analyze in a bit
more detail a bit later but back to you
guys yeah yeah we're going to
keep talking about alakan you're talking
about magnus carlsen being a fan of
alekhine and okay so capablanca the big
genius alekhine maybe you know studying
harder bringing openings into the
picture
who would they resemble today if we if
they take it into today's top chess
players i'm i mean i think you could say
that capablanca was certainly quite
similar to magnus i mean just because
they're very natural players they like
the ending so that was some similarities
alekhine was a much more dynamic player
uh quite a dynamic person by the sounds
of it as well i think he is as we
mentioned earlier married like five
times
i don't have dynamics the right word but
something like that
and um i guess you know when you look at
alakine you you'd have to say
dynamic player like we have ali raza
fruga um maybe you could compare some
aspects of the game to that someone
quite opening theoretical so like gary
kasparov if he uses openings to get good
positions and then turn those into
attacks so dynamic players i'm not
saying magnus is not dynamic but uh
maybe some of these other players yeah
you have a position up here something i
do yeah just initial yeah just to show
you how dynamic uh alakine could be and
this was uh from younger you know from
the start of his career really he was
very strong at an early age and
we can see that his pawn is attacked
obviously that pawn ready to whip the
queen off there um but this didn't stop
alakine from moving his knight
and this looks like a crazy move because
it's like well the queen can be taken
but you know if it's too good to be true
we know what they say it might be a trap
and he grabbed the queen here
but now the thing i really like about
this puzzle i love knights there's
something really nice about the way the
knights move around the board and this
knight now comes back
giving a check to the king
the king has to move so it moves up here
we even use our friendly h-pawn oh yay
of course to give another check the king
comes here and the final move here which
maybe the viewers can find
is to do with the other knight you just
got to find a square where it can give
check
and this knight jumping in there is
actually checkmate so a very pretty
finish and i think very artistic finish
and alekhine was amazingly good at
putting these attacks together so yeah
nice combination
and he became world champion in 1927
overtaking the title from
capoblanca were there some
controversies there with these two uh
you know players and capablanca being
such a popular player as well
yeah i think uh alekhine um and again
i'm saying the english pronunciation i'm
sure i'm going to get in trouble for our
russian friendship but um alekhine was
he was a bit controversial throughout
his life really a lot a lot of things he
did but
in general i think the most
controversial capablanca was okay he won
against camper blanca but he was really
resilient and he didn't really allow
capoblanca to get a rematch so normally
you'll give a chance to get a rematch
but this didn't happen and i can see
we've got another move
over in the game they're coming a bit
quicker and faster now um bishop coming
back to c2 there david um looks pretty
sensible very sensible and it does look
like both players just trying to avoid
the immediate clash between armies both
just taking a time out controlling some
squares and uh sensible once again we'll
dive into the complexities and the
nuances of this move a bit later on but
at the moment still the calm before the
storm
all right well we're heading back to the
1920s then when al khan became world
champion in 1927 he kept his title but
then he lost it so he didn't let
capablanca have a rematch against him he
kept his title he lost it at some point
but he he regained his title also was
alekhine a dominant player of his time
he was very dominant um he played a lot
of tournaments as well and he dominated
those tournaments i think he got 14 and
a half out of 15 something like that
against other great opposition
i mean he did maybe dodge uh kappa
blanca a little bit it would have been
lovely to see them maybe a wise dodge
and um you know he also had an
interesting life he came you know he was
brought up in russia and very hard times
um the war was ravaging and he moved
over to france and he represented france
for a long period of his life and maybe
he he played life like he played chess a
little bit he was adapting to scenarios
trying to do the right thing for his
situation um but interesting and the
most interesting thing is probably his
his friend his best friend his cat right
so yeah i don't know if we
could bring up
oh look at that
so he would actually travel around he
was cats he would yeah and
not very normal really to travel your
cat but he would go everywhere with his
cats so whenever he played a chess
tournament he'd want to take his cat so
his cat was his traveling friend and he
had a very appropriate name as well he
was just called i believe chess
so chess the cat chester yeah so maybe
the first famous chess cat well we saw
the first world champion simon steinitz
with a very nice beard yes uh maybe
you're a little bit inspired by steinitz
are you also a little bit inspired then
by alakine with uh your cats
well yeah i do have a ginger cat charlie
the chess cat so uh he doesn't come
around to chess tournaments with me but
uh yeah you know i like cats yeah yeah
definitely sure all right well alekan he
was born in the soviet union he became
french uh he was french before he became
world champion in 1927
and such an interesting story a dramatic
life he even died
before anyone took his world
championship title away from him and i
know that down in dubai rooney also
knows quite a bit about alexander
alekhine
well yeah for sure they say guy as you
mentioned is an extremely dynamic player
he also had an extremely dynamic life so
we actually had a bit of a you know a
bit of trouble finding out which
pavilion actually to go to we are at the
french pavilion because for the longest
time he lived in france he was a
french citizen and he played for france
for the longest time but he was not born
elijah was not born in france he was
born in the old russia
he was born to an extremely wealthy
aristocratic family
then something happened called the
bolshevik revolution i was not so good
for the aristocrats and they were very
wealthy his father lost his life and
elijah had to flee the country and he
fled to france
so there he played and uh for for many
years and he played a very very great
chess but trouble was still looking for
elijah and of course uh the nazi army
invaded and conquered france and elijah
was not able to get out in time so
throughout the war he actually had to
play under the not safe flag he they
forced him to play under the nazi flag
so i would say that's probably the most
controversial thing he ever did
throughout his life he uh later
expressed that he was very very unhappy
with this that he said that he had no
choice and as you correctly say kaya
after the war he moved to argentina
where he lived until his death he died
holding the title so far the only player
to die holding the title but he wasn't
world champion all the time because max
irvin the dutch brilliant
chess player uh defeated him and
max irv is also an extremely interesting
guy a guy who literally
changed the rules of chess through
mathematics so
that is the next thing we are going to
talk about we are going to head to the
dodge pavilion and i trust that simon
can enlighten us on the style and play
of max irv in the meantime thank you
very much and back to you guys
thanks so much rooney it's fantastic
you're such a big chess fan and been
reading up on chess history and so much
fun to listen to um your stories about
alekhine or aliyah which i guess is the
right pronunciation in russian
all right well he was a is he are you a
big fan david a huge fan and actually
one of my first books was uh a series of
ali khan's best games i think by himself
uh just some annotations about some of
his favorite games and um already in
those days i was thinking i can't attack
like this it's too clever his team is
too strong and
yeah of course colorful character as
well yeah and they did
yeah yeah i was just going to say um
every world champion that i've read
about has
when they were kids studied the games of
alakine and reads his
all right well we had some moves on the
board david we dig a little deeper into
them yeah so we've uh had two moves one
move per player since we last kind of
dove into the position and uh it was
here that we left it with magnus
debating whether the moment was right to
push his pawn in the center and as we
mentioned this would have created
complete chaos it would have been led to
some really forcing sharp lines for
example after pawn step forward a trade
here and magnus he would have had so
much choice he would have been able to
take with the knight the bishop maybe
even with the queen all of these have
pros and cons but magnus decided it was
too much to consider and he delayed he
deferred this decision so instead of
that move he just pushed another pawn
forward maybe supporting this pawn push
later on so he would have another pawn
to recapture and defend that square also
as mentioned opening up the queen's
protection of this pawn in conjunction
with the rook so white should not get
tempted to take this pawn now this would
be a bad material imbalance for white
after a capture here and at the very end
black would have
gained
two pieces just for a rook and a pawn
and the two pieces here the two minor
pieces will be stronger than any rook so
in the end of pontiac instead of going
for that variation simply stepped back
with his bishop and this might look a
bit clumsy all of these four pieces now
are stacked up together but there are
definitely ideas behind the pogchi's
last move he wants to at some point
maybe for example if black just waits uh
white will step back with the queen and
soon a battery will arise against the
black king there's a threat against the
black knight and if the black knight
retreats suddenly the white pawn steps
forward and we understand why napolita
has put his bishops on this square
there's actually a checkmate threat in
the position and uh black's king now in
huge huge trouble so okay napoli
actually with his bishop retreat putting
his bishop on a potentially good square
magnus now needs to find a way to react
i don't think he can wait much longer i
don't think he can just maintain the
status quo it might well be time for
black to push this pawn
and at least clarify the central
situation yeah and i was going to ask
that question you know is the time now
to push in the center and you know just
play d5 break open the position because
like you say if you wait too much longer
then you know all that pressure is going
to make it impossible to break and then
the position will become very unpleasant
yeah these bishops still strong but at
least now you have creative threats
should we look in what happens if he
tries to break in the center now yup uh
i'm sorry so uh yep this position sorry
after d5 i guess white will take it
black has a choice of which way to
recapture you can take back actually in
four different ways he's played at
magnus he has
decided not to wait any longer the game
is definitely heating up now he's pushed
this pawn forward white will take this
pawn i think no matter what you have to
capture and now magnus has a choice pawn
takes bishop takes knight takes or even
queen takes it's all about this square
the d5 square and
first instinct would be just to play
pawn takes pawn and force the white
knight to make a decision maybe even to
step back but then again now black has
two isolated pawns white doesn't have
any isolated pawns so long term this is
risky in an endgame black would be
struggling and we know magnus doesn't
want long-term deficiencies in his
position
that being said if you take with the
queen again you might have to consider a
few things but also once the queens
disappear at some point maybe this pawn
will be attacked
for example here white could consider
maybe capturing this pawn and black
needs justification for doing this maybe
you're okay maybe you move the knight
out the way you're attacking lots of
things
but uh calculation needs to be done here
either way i think after this pawn takes
pawn move magnus will continue thinking
and uh what do you think ivanka which
way to recapture this guy
oh
with a bishop bishop where the bishop
was my vibe okay because you know i was
a little bit worried after knight takes
you know the line that you
demonstrated so after knight takes here
maybe the white queen might even step
back again threatening some nasty sneaky
checkmates and you have to you have to
make a pawn you have to push a pawn
actually to defend against that uh
deadly threat
and
maybe you're okay maybe you're okay it's
a bit shaky right it does feel a little
bit shaky because now the you know
having provoked that weakness the queen
can actually step forward again later
maybe he's trying to sneak in in this
diagonal exactly so
that line doesn't really appeal to me
too much but a bishop takes and queen
takes as you showed i didn't like that
at all i felt it
was possible riding on the edger and uh
kind of bishop takes is there anything
wrong with that so i can see i think
there's nothing wrong with any of the
recaptures to be honest i mean
some may be slightly better than others
but none of them lose on the spot at
least and
we would see a trade of rooks at some
point maybe white would take these rooks
off the board maybe the white knight can
jump in
yeah it's not winning the game for white
but it's slightly unpleasant for black
potentially
especially if white can obtain the
bishop pair white's bishops will be very
strong and next move white can eliminate
one of the strong black bishops
so uh okay current position is this one
uh not sorry not that one it's this one
and uh right now you're not actually
debating whether to capture this pawn
and uh force things to accelerate you
said it's heating up what what you mean
by that is it easier to make errors is
it easier to see that the players are
ambitious well the position is opened
yeah and when the position has opened
then every single move counts you know
we just saw in some of those lines where
white was attacking a rook and a bishop
white was threatening checkmate and so
every move starts to matter
i feel like we have to run through some
of those lines again like i'm thinking
how how to which capture i can't make up
my mind i'm not sure yet i mean we'll go
into that in a moment i just want to
think as well about what why
nepomiacci's uh still is he considered
moved pushing his pawn forward
surely not no that doesn't
yeah i think there's only one move that
i would be considering here paul takes
pawn maybe he's just trying to look into
the future four or five moves ahead
but uh what other options does white
have here if you don't take black's pawn
then you might have to just start
retreating and that's not a good sign so
simon what do you think good timing by
magnus this last pawn break his pawn
push yeah i think so i mean i think he
has to play something in the center of
why is white's just gonna have a space
advantage and d5 is uh extremely
thematic you want to liberate your
pieces and oh he has played e5 he has so
he's pushed on so that's a bit of a
surprise there wow yeah i dismiss that
sorry if i feel guilty now i don't know
because i actually i actually thought
when we were going through the lines of
pawn taste porn i was thinking hang on a
second i can't see a good recapture so
ponte porn fishing attacking the night i
agree with you david it doesn't look as
good as uh
pawn yeah so after black did push
forward white has bypassed this attack
so instead of taking and asking the
question to black how are you going to
recapture uh janna probably she pushed
forward and this is a counter-attack yes
the white knight will drop
potentially but then again the black
knight would drop and if we compare the
pawn structures in this end game for
example if the queens disappear as well
if we see a trade and suddenly blacks
pawns we see that they're extremely weak
this is isolated these are doubled this
is isolated and this is also isolated
whereas the white pawns are nicely
coordinated nicely connected these two
as well could potentially defend each
other so
end games maybe not so appealing for
magnus but
for example if the knight if the knight
moves is janna ponetti just gonna jump
into the position and he's gonna jump in
with his knights and he actually had
this type of night yesterday i remember
magnus had this type of night with white
and black also had a very strong knight
at some point but if we saw this night
eliminated then suddenly these two
bishops i think are just too strong
there's actually a direct threat of
checkmate white's queen wants to take
this pawn in teaming up with his bishop
and
okay so okay sorry if the black move is
four the black knight is forced to move
um that means it maybe has to go into
somewhere very daring right i mean maybe
you have to try c5 here i mean yeah the
thing is i this is one of the positions
we talked about you have all this uh
building up to the crescendo to to the
violence and the violence is now
happening on the board
if i was black i'd try to play with as
much tempo as i could and i think a move
such as pawn to c5 just pushing that
pawn up to attack the queen
makes sense i want to push the queen
away and i want to try to avoid you
going queen d3 in some positions but i
don't know if he's played that it looks
like he's taken something
and he's up to the i'm very surprised
he's gone for this ending um
he must have something up his sleeve
here because as you pointed out david
it looks structurally really bad i mean
there's two ways to assess the position
the pawn structure in your pieces and if
you're just going on the pawn structure
magnus would be in trouble but he's got
an idea clearly here okay so the queens
disappear before white recaptures the
knight so white temporarily a piece down
but after this queen trade we will see
white take this knight back and uh yeah
suddenly this is a big weakness these
guys are doubled
i'm not so confident from magnus david
we also talked about this rook rook over
of ivanka's the rover the rook swinger
and um
it's one of those positions where if
black does have a capture on f6 that's
going to become certainly an idea maybe
after taking on f6
if you want to go super aggressive
something like this yeah playing for
checkmate even though the queens are
gone yeah those bishops they're just
raking bishops um i have a suggestion
instead of capturing the pawn
what happens if you were to go okay
there's a lot of danger in the position
let's uh play my bishop out my dark
square bishop and yeah that's that's the
move i want
and uh
just try to relieve the pressure a
little bit yeah this is clever actually
just hoping as well for white to trade
the bishops on black's terms and
suddenly these two pawns are connected
once again and they become very very
powerful they'll start marching down the
board i guess white would have to ignore
this trade just pretend that there was
no tension here and uh maybe for example
pawn takes pawn
and if you want to regain this pawn
which is protected by white bishop then
you'd have to trade at some point
and uh
maybe it's not so bad for black but
still structurally these two are not
necessarily better than whites one
so
are you saying you're getting worried
for magnus carlsen now i think he should
be fine but he's got to be accurate and
energetic uh normally when you have a
bad pawn structure for example in the
situation that's now about to arrive on
the board
after queen takes queen sorry um okay he
has taken with the rook so we will reach
this position when you have a bad pawn
structure as black you have to be
energetic you have to compensate uh
for the uh for the lack of positional
um pluses in your position you have to
compensate with dynamic dynamic play i
really like this bishop b4 move that uh
ivanka pointed out because uh
as you say as well david is it's one of
those players yeah
really really nice find by ivanka there
and it's uh it's one of those positions
where
you want to get to as near to a draw
quickly as you can so you want to swap
off you want to eliminate things
and you might have to suck up a little
bit of pressure but as we know magnus is
world champion for a number of reasons
and his defensive play is is one of
those reasons so
things clarifying though and we should
be able to make a good assessment in a
couple of years time okay so we
predicted this white captured a pawn so
temporarily white is a pawn up and
temporarily white has a four versus two
advantage on this side of the board but
uh this intruder will disappear soon and
uh shoot yana pominacci now play for a
win
i think he would like to if possible
it's not clear exactly how despite the
fact black has these weaknesses not it's
not clear how you get to them it's not
clear how you create any past pawns as
white later on so for example you could
trade here and okay there's no rush to
take this pawn for example blacks rooks
could start maybe entering open lines
both of these guys are pretty good
actually these two rooks or maybe you
could even try and jump in at some point
um into white's camp yeah i'm sure this
is magnus's idea because we talked about
pawn structure and pieces and his pawn
structure is pretty bad he can't do
anything with the black pawn so he's got
to look at his pieces and
you've got to look at your pieces how to
improve them the black bishop at some
point could come into that central
square
in the middle but using those works
seems seems really normal thing to do
here
try to get active try to exchange off
but there is a danger in a lot of
endings i feel here with with black's
pawn so if all the rooks are removed
from the board
i'm pretty sure you take white white to
win the ending because the white king
can come and
you know it could be for example yeah
let's just get those rooks off somehow
yeah
if all the rooks disappear then black is
simply yeah i think in trouble yeah
these three will beat these two
whereas on the other side black will not
make any progress but i just feel by
virtue of the open lines and uh white's
pawn two pawns on the left side aren't
grey either and i'm just thinking
actually after bishop takes bishop and
the rose come into the game i think
maybe
magnus might be feeling quite positive
if he's able to coordinate the rooks
especially on the second row
and uh it's not easy to defend that weak
pawn uh sitting on a4 yeah yeah i mean
exactly
i guess white can play rookie d1 and try
to put a king on e1 but definitely black
has that activity at the moment and
activity is very important i mean
i would say you know general sum up
there should be a draw but
it feels like maybe yan is playing for
the two results and this is like a
perfect scenario to be in and what the
two results means is you're playing
probably going to be a draw but you have
the winning chances i can't unless a
mistake has made see magnus winning
winning this position yeah but draw draw
looking looking lightly but we're gonna
have some more adventures first
it's definitely not a dead draw but
maybe with best play black activity
especially with the rooks will
compensate for the deficient pawn
structure
and they're quite playing quite fast now
after
both of them having long things at some
moment in the game both both players
spent nearly half an hour on one move
yeah and clearly they'd calculated ahead
that's why these top players are so good
it's not because they're indecisive and
it's not as if they're freezing for
those 30 minutes they are really really
making these hard hard decisions
would you have rushed with capturing the
pawn on g7 probably not but
i don't necessarily think there's
anything wrong with it either you would
you were preferring i was preferring to
mobilize rooks um so i was either
thinking put the rook on the other rope
that's not working put that on the b
line and then threatened to come into
the second row
i felt there was no rush did you see
that stare from jana pogniacci looking
straight he's got the best stairs i mean
if there's a staring competition he wins
it hand out i mean he's got he reminds
me kasparov kasparov was like the best
actor in chess he was he was really uh
you mentioned his his aura his aura was
powerful and he could use his body to
translate energy to the board it seemed
and he had this his opponent would play
a bad move and he'd be like
he'd let his opponent know and uh yan
yan just reminds me of that i don't
think he does it consciously i think
it's just a subconscious thing he does
but um it must be a bit intimidating to
to have that you know
have that stare and again there's
another english grandmaster i can think
of who uh very famously stares straight
in your eyes and he doesn't take his
eyes off you for the entire game for the
entire game it would just stare right in
your eyes and uh
yeah i i think there was a famous story
once when he was playing another english
grand master and that grand master said
do you want my phone number or something
it's like you know which was mind games
again you know so uh but it's it's quite
off-putting mm-hmm
okay so simon your plan is coming into
fruition
bringing the king towards the center
yeah makes a lot of sense here so yeah
once the queens are off the kings are
never going to be in any danger right so
they might as well help out
and uh now white i guess is also ready
to evict any intrusions by the black
rooks
um yeah if the black rook for example on
the default just comes in to the second
rank white can just challenge it with
his own rook
maybe black's plan here is to try to get
rid of this bishop i mean if i was black
here king f6 bishop f5
i want to get to a rook ending my my
rooks are on the open lines as you've
pointed out and i just want to get rid
of the bishops so i can try to get to
some of these key squares for my rook so
that's the way i might be looking at
this to try and get rid of the bishops
as black you've always got to consider
especially in the ending what pieces
will help your position if you exchange
them and what will make them worse and
we've said that if you exchange all the
rooks off that's a bad exchange to black
but maybe the bishop exchanges the way
to go i don't think he'll get it in but
you can try yeah
really interesting actually and that's
very instructive any end game or even
any middle game you need to ask yourself
which pieces which trades will benefit
me and maybe magnus is going to go for
this actually the more i look at it the
more i like it if uh okay let's say
white just makes a move uh if we do see
this bishop trade just to highlight the
squares you mentioned simon now that the
white white light squared bishop is gone
the black rook has access to this square
also supported by porn and the other
rook has access to this square
and both of those would team up against
this poor white pawn so
this it's not 100 clear who this would
favor but it does look like black would
be happier if the bishops leave the
board and also in general right it
doesn't hurt to put your king nearer in
the center if all the rooks disappear at
least you're quicker to get into the
middle and then you can choose which
side to run to
so that would be very sensible maybe
white could stop this by i'm not sure
lifting up a rook just to try and create
a pin if this ever happens
but uh
at least then the white rooks committed
itself to a square might not want to be
on
so yeah i like that idea alternatives
would be just to slide across right
to try and come in and if there's a rook
trade maybe a set of
one set of trades is okay because then
the black rook could try and come in
but uh it's not entirely clear
because if the rook does come in why can
just defend and then slide across and
evict again i mean it's a crazy idea of
going rook b3 with a bishop on c2 but i
think that's a little bit too much i
mean
uh just but yeah okay i don't believe it
but this sacrifice yeah i mean it is an
exchange and it's probably just
a great way to lose but i mean you maybe
have to think about it the pawn is very
strong and
uh you might be able to cause some in
the right moment right because here i
mean why can't it's bishop at the right
moment this could be a really dangerous
idea there's maybe something to think
about exactly so there's lots of things
still going on um it's going to be a
long game i think this one um i i still
prefer white just because of the
structure but
um i think magnus will be okay yeah it
feels like magnus should be okay but he
needs to be energetic and that's why
we've been talking about computers a lot
today right so it says 0.0 the computer
thinks with best players to draw but
it doesn't necessarily show us whose
position is easier to play and who the
stakes are higher for if magnus is
careless for five moves maybe the
computer will start saying plus one plus
two for white but i think if napolita's
slightly careless for two or three moves
i think he should still be able to draw
so i mean i think magnus has made a
career uh winning 0.0 positions or 0.1
positions this is this is something he's
done but this is one of those positions
where i don't think he's going to be
pushing uh certainly not
do you think good strategy then from
napoli actually take all the risk out of
the position and just before the rest
day he can push now for the next
10 20 moves at least i think he'd be
very happy with his position because he
shouldn't lose i mean i think that's
clear that with correct play shouldn't
lose and maybe he can just play without
risk-free uh going to the rest day with
with at least an equal score
uh but one thing's the shortest world
championships has it's been very
exciting so far
um and it's people who are massively
backing magnus i mean
it's not going that way at the moment
um yeah on that subject i've heard many
grand masters actually say you know
magnus will be
will have an easy journey actually to it
will be such a
straightforward match difference in
class but you know absolutely not from
these last three games we've seen the
difference in quality i think they've
been matching each other actually every
step of the way magnus has forced
napomniashi to be
resourceful and
find good defensive moves on occasion
but
i mean both sides very
i've been very impressed with both of
them yeah it feels like napoli actually
he's leveled up over the last year or so
and he's definitely playing on magnus's
standard right now
and uh i had an interesting chat a
couple of days ago at the good night pub
uh with a norwegian grand master and he
said he gave 98 percent chance that
magnus would win and i was just shocked
i thought i mean um he's playing so well
yeah and uh okay meanwhile 98 is
crazy he was saying crazy i was saying
crazy games 100 point difference between
their ratings but crazy in one-on-one
encounters it's a completely different
one the teams as well that have been
working intensely
let's remember jan has a plus score i
think against magnus so one the only
player to have plus score so magnus has
only ever beaten him in one classical
game right but it was their most recent
one
the most recent decisive result they
played several times since then
yeah okay we have some moves on the
board okay black's rook took an open
file and white's rook has challenged for
that open file so we could see a trade
of rooks on the b line right now
what do you think will black rush to
trade
will black just bring the king closer to
the center
okay he's bringing the king yeah so your
idea simon
yeah i mean if you can get this bishop
f5 move in it just at the right time it
feels he's going to be absolutely okay
um to trade those bishops i don't know
if
yang can get any minute he's getting
blood out the stone that's that's what
you need to do in such situations but
i th you know at the moment i can't see
it i can't see how he's going to do it
so if magnus was white in this uh
situation because you're saying it's
basically a two result game right now
it's draw or maybe slight chances
brianna pomnyacci if if magnus was with
the white pieces with his style of
squeezing until the very end would you
have then thought it would be a long
game magnus
trying trying trying to get that win
definitely i think he'd at least take it
to move 40 and then he'd he'd have an
extra hour and he'd find ways to maybe
set traps or um slowly start making
these small gains step by step but
um probably actually we did see it in
game one he as soon as he slightly
turned things around on v40 he pretty
much took a draw yeah he didn't even try
to press
and uh
yeah it's difficult to call but it feels
like napoli actually if he gets a chance
he will try at least to put some
pressure on what is it like from risk
what is it like for magnus to sit at the
board well he's not there right now but
but to play this game
basically knowing that he's only playing
for a draw
i mean with the black pieces it's not
the worst case scenario if you're white
and you're only playing for a draw then
it's a bit depressing just you lose the
moral victory but uh
he's quite a realist he's quite a
pragmatic player sometimes especially
world championship matches we've seen in
the last two
matches there but if it's a draw if the
opponent's played well he's okay with
that and uh he'll move on and he knows
that if he does hold magnus in this game
after the rest day he's got white he's
got more whites left than black
uh so yeah it's
what if he holds this i think he'll be
what pretty happy what piece or what
situation on the board foreign
gives him the better position even if
slightly
all the rooks off the board and talking
of all the rooks of the world he's going
for that now could we see a repetition
of moose actually with uh rook takes
rook and now napomniashi will go
rook
chat well we'll challenge his rook yeah
instantly and then magnus will say no
and move it and then they could chuckle
they could yo yeah they could j
i mean you also maybe have to think
about taking bishop f5 but that's that's
just not going to work is it so no no
not at all too maybe we can show this
yeah just trying to swap everything off
but yeah it's a bad exchange so we're
not expecting magnus carson to take
these rooks off the board right now
simon you mentioned this trade and uh
possibly black stepping forward with the
bishop but unfortunately um this is why
we talk about exchanges right just
because
right now these two are basically the
same as this one and uh therefore white
simply has a three versus two advantage
on the side i think he might have taken
that rook off okay so he has taken the
rook he's very confident this ending um
i'm surprised i must admit because i was
expecting ivanka's move of just running
away with the rook and maintaining the
status quo he's traded he's put his king
in the middle
what do you think well i think he'll hot
i think he will hold this because he's
because he's magnus but i i i wouldn't
like to i don't mean maybe it's
absolutely okay because the pawn on a4
is on a light square but
i i would i wouldn't like to be black
here uh personally i mean magnus will
show us the way i'm sure but i think
he's got a very concrete idea in mind
actually he knows that he will guarantee
uh getting a pawn to this square where
he can blockade on the dart squares if
white for example were able to somehow
say if black just waited um if white
were able to somehow get some checks in
and get these pawns rolling these three
get them marching up the board then i
think white's just winning yeah but
in the current position uh if white
pushes forward then the black pawn steps
forward and there's no way that you'll
ever be able to get in with the white
king so could you could you okay you
have to maybe stop this plan can you can
you try to go
h4 and g3 but that's the h pawns could
be two weeks still
so this is this is a very good plan yeah
the porn is still going to match up
because if there's a trade then suddenly
yeah
i was wondering whether you could be
crafty and try to
sacrifice something for the time
okay
yeah just so that you can get the time
to
come in
with your king you would love to push
this pawn forward right right just try
and check but it does come at the cost
of this guy exactly and so the idea is
then okay this okay well they didn't
play that maybe after f5 you can try g3
uh this is uh
agnes rushing forward with this pawn to
act as a blockader you mentioned trying
g3 simon pushing the spawn but you just
push anyway yeah okay you can put your
pawns all on dark squares but the
problem is the white king never gets in
now
um
for example just park this bishop in the
middle i mean again it goes back to the
pawn structure in pieces and uh the king
is a piece people forget that the king
is a very important piece and black's
king on e5 is a much superior piece to
white's king and that that is holding
the balance uh for magnus
do we think
this world championships could be
14 draws
like the last couple of world
championships what do we reckon
i just can't see it i can't see it but
yeah i think that there will be a lot of
draws yes yeah but the way that these
two have been playing yeah and uh also
the complex the complexity of the
positions that they found themselves in
i just think it's a matter of time
before someone makes a big mistake and
there is a decisive result
yeah napoleon actually doesn't look
happy right now no just had his head in
his hands and he's realizing he's just a
move or too
too slow
to create any chances
yeah i think you can see there again you
can you can read him sometimes and that
strikes me as he's giving up winning
chances just with that body language
and his last move as well not
necessarily improving the position just
putting his bishop yeah on a
they're not allowed to uh overdraw
before move 40
but they cannot of course have a move
repetition is that what we're about to
see you think i've i find that rule very
strange that you can't offer it because
okay i can understand it in
other tournaments where there's lots of
players but it's the world championships
you know you're playing one-on-one
why can't you offer a draw yeah
psychology just to tempt your opponent
or see what their mindset is yeah just
you know i think i find that peculiar
rule in the world championships but i'll
get myself in trouble again
very good at that generally that was a
very good point yeah but why why can't
they offer a draw there's no one else
involved and it's not like they're going
to want to play quick draws no you know
to have a quick day you know there's no
reason to have a quick draw ever so
yeah it's strange i've got to say guys i
predicted before this game that it would
be a roy lopez that it will be a draw in
42 moves so i'm hoping that they get to
move 42 i did the same as you but i said
55 so i'm sure you're gonna get there
no i don't see it we're not even gonna
move forward yet are we we're not even
gonna ask what are you doing
me neither okay
bottom place again although i still have
some chances
if they somehow find some repetition
now they're repeating here bishop c2
bishop b1 is that repetition um well
black's paul is now on a difference oh
okay okay
but they might just look at each other
and kind of yeah and say like okay i
think magnus is looking at a scoresheet
they're maybe looking to see can i offer
a draw even i potentially think they can
offer no they can't say thank you what
would happen if they did would the
player who offered the draw be sort of
lost
so we're not quite there so maybe 42
david maybe i think it might happen on
move 40 actually imagine if you get a
full score wow that would be impressive
that would be very impressive yeah i
should mention as well just good
strategy there uh i mean a draw will
happen but good strategy for magnus
carlsen he's got a light-squared bishop
so he puts his pawns on dark squares
that's uh just something for everyone at
home not every bushben game is drawn
this one happens to be but uh if you get
a chance put your pawns on opposite
squares to your bishop your bishop will
control the light squares your pawns
control the dark squares and also here
because white has a light square bishop
he cannot target your pawns while they
sit on dark squares
this is just looking like a draw isn't
it i mean uh there's there's no way
really either side can do anything you
need to get the king in you need to get
a past porn
uh i don't see how this is going to be
possible uh to do so um and yeah see on
his face now i know coming at you he he
knows there's nothing to be done white
will never be in trouble because you
have a poor majority three versus two on
the right but yeah
but yeah uh you can't make any progress
either no
it should just be a draw and uh the key
thing is that uh magnus should not get
too ambitious and start pushing pawns
i'm thinking primarily of that pawn on
h6 shouldn't touch that pawn it's on a
dark square if you put it on a light
square it will get fixed on the light
square and it will be a target for
white's bishop oh yeah looking up at
magnus okay
and then again okay i was wondering
about this movie he's putting his pawn
on a light square which is not the
strategy to do but um which means he's
giving up all winning chances uh but i
guess he's just going to put his king
next to that and just just do nothing
literally so uh it's a bad strategy but
for here it's okay yeah i mean
you know there's no way magnus can get
through i mean if the the last move that
magnus played he's trying to get his
king the only way the black king can get
into the position is doing that creepy
crawly method into g3 so it sort of
comes on the dark squares uh down
towards white's pawns but that that will
be stopped that will be stopped yeah so
is there any kind of
i mean if magnus does get his king as
far as up as it can possibly go so i'm
thinking the h4 square i mean is there
any kind of chance that
magnus can trick napolmehi because there
aren't any waiting moves
yeah maybe napoli actually has to be
slightly careful here because if okay he
has pushed a pawn that's good if he just
slid his king across here black's king
would come in and uh even if we reach a
situation like this it might just be
what we call zugswang where any move for
white worsens his position if the king
steps back the black king comes in if
the bishop steps back he has to keep an
eye on the spawn then the black bishop
comes in
and suddenly not easy at all maybe this
would even be very strong for black but
uh of course janna pogba he's too good
to miss such things and he does push
this pawn forward uh just a few moments
ago he pushed this ball forward to stop
the black king coming closer
and uh now if we catch up with the play
out players they are about to agree a
draw i think there's no way in for the
black king simply david's going to get a
full if you get is it move 42.
it's going to be 39. it could be amazing
it's going to be 42. you could get you
could get there i mean can white play g4
i mean this is the i mean it doesn't
really do anything i feel but you
you're trying to get a past pawn right
so where why you know we could try
g3 yeah g4 or g3 i don't know which one
is
maybe
one of these i mean yeah just hoping
that there might be a trade and that
later the white king can sneak in yeah
um i get a passport you know it's an
ending
but okay this is still a draw even if uh
this is
played this is still a draw because i
don't think white's king can get much
further into the position he hasn't even
gone for this the underpony actually
but uh also even if you push with this
pawn i think black can just wait i think
this this square is covered and it's
about to be a draw let's go back to the
players it's a move 42 david oh oh
yeah it's going to be forward
did you get it
with 41.
perfect score on
uh the magnus natural prediction
challenge it's a draw in game three
between jan and pognation minus carlsen
and uh it's a quick draw let's say here
if they talk again today
response
islands from the playing menu today no
discussion no discussion today jana
pognyacci is
leaving they have only played for
two and a half hours right
three hours and 42 minutes
no
oh no it's only four yeah yeah yeah two
hours two hours and 45 minutes so it's a
uh in classical chess a quite a quick
game a quite uh quick draw after 41
moves
it is over but this again
an interesting game and we were
especially
um
interested in
the game following
that analysis from
the dark web
yeah we have so much intrigue right and
uh as soon as the game actually veered
away from known territory it was
actually at this point uh this was where
we had to guess the move where simon was
worrying sweating about this bishop
retreat but um maybe janna pogba
actually not so familiar with the ideas
maybe he got to this point i mean this
is move 20. that's impressive
preparation but he didn't know any
further and uh this pawn push just felt
maybe a bit too slow if he'd step back
with the queen magnus would have had to
be very careful of potential pawn breaks
instead after this pawn push this
innocent pawn push
it felt like the game was fizzling out
but magnus with this pawn push now
did manage to equalize quite easily
this is the kind of game which i uh i
think there's a yes we're gonna head
down to tanya for reaction for minus
uh that was the norwegian channel
asking whenever some questions
um you were going to say simon something
about the i was going to say before the
match this is the kind of
game that i thought would happen more
often i thought it would be like uh
white trying to push looking like he had
some advantage but then
when magnus has the black pieces
defending incredibly well and maybe even
well surprising me a bit with the
position and the resourcefulness and the
position and uh he's gonna be very hard
to break down and uh you know to beat if
he plays like that with black with e4 e5
i don't know how uh jan's gonna get
through but he he seems to do everything
very very cleverly there magnus i mean
obviously yan played well at the same
time uh but this d5 move was perfectly
timed and uh he knew the ending was okay
okay we're heading down yeah i wasn't
thrilled to have this ending but uh i
felt that
it was generally
well within the drawing range
and
yeah i was happy to liquidate of course
to this pure bishop's ending because i
get to centralize the king and push push
the pawn and create a barrier now at
least traditionally world championship
hold with black try and push with white
seems to be the strategy how do you feel
about the positions you've gotten so far
with the black pieces happy with the
prep happy with the way it's going
yeah the positions are are fine pretty
much um
today um
i was trying to play a bit of a bit of a
sideline
to
try and get a game but yeah eventually
i just had to
how to try and liquidate uh which i
guess is
what you normally end up doing doing in
these positions anyway is that what
rookie it was all about
yeah rookie eight
it's really really
dumb it's a really really dumb move
because usually you would try to go to
rookie 8 without
d6 um but yeah it turns out even here he
was
he was well prepared and
he um
didn't give me any
even slight chances to to to play so i
was happy all right and finally three
big games tomorrow's arrested relieved
yeah um
[Music]
it's good to get a get a rest day um
now i've had two black games um so far
so the result is okay but obviously
um gotta
try and create some chances at some
points thanks max
finishing off with a smile on his face
uh magnus carlsen talking about the game
here some notation can you take us
through what magnus is talking about
david yeah so first of all magnus
mentioned the barrier he was happy to
set up right at the end and that was
actually in the final position just to
explain to the viewers once more white
simply can't break through white has a
better pawn structure but this king is
trapped uh it just can't get past these
two pawns so um that was the first thing
but also right back if we rewind all the
way to the opening magnus mentioned this
position where he said rookie 8 it's a
dumb move but it was his preparation so
clearly that's his strategy to surprise
his opponent he said it's a dumb move
because he could have played this
earlier and saved a bit of time but
playing it now did well the intention
was to lure napoleon out of his
preparation it turned out napolita was
very well prepared up until move 20 or
round move 20 and uh
at this point we saw uh later on after
the bishop came forward that was where
magnus said okay it's fine after white
pushed this pawn forward he liquidated
he swapped off all the pieces he traded
queens knights and everything and
eventually got down to the draw so could
have been better could have been worse
from the world champion's point of view
and he's saying it's a good result the
two games with the black pieces after
the first three games they are still
tied jan and pognation magnus carlsen do
you think yana pomnyacci simon is happy
with the situation after three games um
i think he'd be mildly happy um he
didn't really get many chances in that
game he missed some chances in game two
so did magnus he's
he did say like with the white pieces
this is important that's where he's
gonna get his points from he hasn't got
a point for the white pieces so
uh it just but it just seems very equal
to me i mean uh i think both sides have
got things they should positives they
should concentrate on and uh we'll have
to see if magnus can use those white
pieces to uh create some chances as he
said there in the next couple of games
yeah and you were updating us ivanka on
every move that was following some
opening preparations something that had
been analyzed only two days ago what do
you think is going on in the two teams
right now
well i think there will be some words
with someone you know as to how this
analysis was it was allowed to be
available to the public but i mean in
the big deal i mean it's not really a
big deal i don't think because uh
it was just a one-off opening and i do
think that magnus will be varying within
the rude opposite
all right um we will we are waiting for
the press conference of course to start
where we will also heard from miana
pomnyacci usually it starts
in 10 to 15 minutes we're gonna head
back down to dubai for
to rooney who's been i think hanging out
with someone who's been at every single
world championship match that magnus
carlsen has played
well hello and welcome to our first
installment of our new concept that we
call chess players in buggies getting
tea we are outside the deck that is
inside inside they they are playing and
we are here with uh woman grandmaster
anastasia kalwich you are the press
officer for this event is this correct
uh actually not the first officer for
this event but i've been the press
officer for the previous world
championship matches yes nice to see you
so nice that you could join us for this
uh in the driver's seat we have a eskill
famous from the skill segments and
please take us away and i will let's
talk just a little bit of course
pleasure
how
how many chess world championships have
you been at
ah good question actually uh my first
world championship was in 2010 when we
shanand played against whistling tapalo
it was in bulgaria in sofia and that was
a i was a photographer at that time but
since 2012 until 2016 so for the three
world championship matches i was the
press officer for for the events where
magnus actually was taking part so since
magnus became the world champion or oh
no before that when gelson played with
an ant also in 2012 i was there yes and
uh after all i was in chennai i was in
sochi and i was in new york for in 2016.
so you have an a lot of experience at
these matches is there anything you
would say is different about this one in
particular
okay first of all we are in dubai you
know
we're here in expo
and
i think it's well organized uh world
championship match and we have still
something is still the same we still
have magnus here so it's like
the same thing
after all and um
it's really interesting match
i mean literally it's unclear who is
going to win and maybe there's something
which makes it also very exciting for
everybody i mean um taking into account
the previous score between these players
i mean so i mean looking forward to see
how the games will develop
thank you very much for the inside it
looks like we are getting to the cheap
place now so eskel has gotten us to the
awesome place where we can have some
nice tea thank you very much for the
insight and back to you guys in the
studio
thanks so much
it looks so warm and nice down there in
dubai tanya is of course also on ground
and taking us into the action of
everything that's going on quite quick
draw today tanya but again a very
interesting game
guy we've had three draws so far but
they haven't disappointed i think
today's was definitely more strategic
more solid than what we've seen in the
first two games but i think we were
speaking about this at the start of game
three that you know with the rest day
coming up the players might have a
slightly more solid safety first
approach
and i think overall a very high class
draw played out now there's so much
activity going on in dubai there are of
course chess players from across the
world who've traveled to see the games
but not just chess players chess fans
have come here as well to enjoy this
world championship match in a very
iconic venue the dubai expo and i've got
one such special guest with me it's
eubert menard who's here all the way
from malaysia for this match thank you
for joining us ubert
yeah thank you um it was just out of
coincidence actually that i arrived here
we had a meeting for a week in the
northern emirates
and i know these world championships
that don't come every day so uh
yeah i was just lucky to be here in
dubai and i took the chance to come and
it's been a wonderful experience
actually
yeah and the games the games are pretty
good actually
i think now with the rest day coming i
think
now uh magnus will have white pieces so
maybe we'll see a very explosive game
fourth game looking forward to that
you were supposed to leave dubai a
couple of days ago and then you found
out the match is happening and decided
to stay back i i knew the match was
there but uh
you know i took the extra days of course
and uh managed to get a ticket as well
and uh yeah i'm very happy to be here
and meet all of you guys
great experience is there is there a
player you're rooting for here
which one do you have a favorite here a
player you're rooting for
no not in particular i think is good
i think is good any opponent right for
magnus is a challenge
it's good to see some changes
i think jan is a very explosive player
so i think it's uh
i think even if you see somebody win a
game it's long long
it's not finished so quickly it's i
think it's 14 games right so
there's a long way to go and as a chess
enthusiast what do you think about the
vibe and the atmosphere here in dubai
well i mean it comes at the same time as
the expo 2020 right so x for 2020 is the
biggest one that's ever been uh you know
dubai is always the biggest
and the largest and so it's the same
here i think they did a great job
actually i was quite impressed actually
with the setup
so big so huge uh very comfortable
seating a little bit cold though but we
got through that otherwise people might
fall asleep um it's a long uh i think
overall they are pretty good to have it
in dubai
oh thank you so much it's so nice to
hear that you had a good time at the
match
thank you
well that's what it is all about chess
fans from all across the world
enthusiasts tourists they're all here
for the world championship match to
witness who will become the next world
chess champion tomorrow is a rest day
and i'm expecting a big fight as magnus
takes on yana pomniacci with the white
pieces in game four all right thanks so
much tanya and that game will of course
also be magnus carlsen's birthday game
for in dubai in two days
but we are still waiting for press
conference now after game three before
that happens we're gonna have a quick
commercial break
[Applause]
today
more than ever when the world comes
together to create a better tomorrow
it's going to be
larger
magic
magic with music with architecture with
colors magic with celebration with your
safety
from here there and everywhere for six
whole months day and night join the
making of a new world starting october
1st
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
i'm ahead of the game
[Music]
[Music]
i'm a prodigy logically i'm impossible
[Music]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
this is john
john loves to study chess
[Music]
this is david loves to study chess as
well but efficiently
john spends more time setting up the
board and figuring out what's on the
page of his books and he gets to study
david likes to take it easy
and use his time wisely
[Music]
david has finished his exercise for
today
john should try the same
[Music]
okay so let's send the challenge
ah
here is challenging
nice graphics easy to see
[Music]
what are you thinking about you're
looking how it can be the most painful
exactly
okay fine funny
that i give him a phone
he wants to be even rude
[Music]
now anyone can learn and improve their
chess skills with the world champion
magnus carlson
[Music]
the magnus trainer app is packed with
fun mini games in interactive training
content playable anytime anywhere get
the magnus trainer available in the app
store and google play
welcome back to the chess 24 global
broadcast we are waiting for the press
conference after game three in dubai
that one two ended with the draw magnus
calls negan and pogbachy are tied after
three games tomorrow will be a rest day
do you think that's very welcome for
them now after three intense games yeah
we heard magnus admit he needed a rest
uh also it's just nice to have some time
where you can chill you can study some
chess you can actually have a proper
chat with your team and
i know that both players they will be
feeling energized in game four and that
game i think will be highlighted in
magnus's calendar as the time to start
making his move to start throwing
everything at the ponyachi what is rest
days about do you think simon in the
world championship match um well i know
for magnus um it'll be sport he loves
doing a bit of sport just uh just feel
good um hanging out with his friends i
think there's no point like uh
looking at loads of lights i mean he's
been doing that for his whole life um
he's been doing that for the last month
i think it's time just to feel good and
just to feel relaxed go and go and have
a cup of tea with your friends yeah play
some football or something that's that's
a great way to rest do they do they are
at all sort of talk with their teams
about preparations or do the team work
and the players relax
i think in magnus's case i think the
team very much does the work and are
there on hand to help magnus relax just
play as many games as possible because
you know one thing about magnus is that
he can never fully detach himself away
from the game you know you see that even
before this world championship match
started he was still on blitz websites
just uh playing four and a half hours of
blitz
that's just the way his mind works and
he's like working things out so i think
he will very much do what simon said you
know just relax but then at the same
time play some games against his
teammates yeah and do you think david
that it will be some cleaning up in the
teams if it turns out that someone has
forgotten to make that analysis private
i think for sure there will be some
stern words it might not come down to
nepogiacci or magnus carlsen to deliver
those words to the teammates but i mean
the bosses of those teams they will want
to make sure that nothing leaks out and
it's tiny tiny margins at this level
we've seen both players obtain such a
high level at an early stage and uh one
small slip like that might derail them
psychologically or might derail them on
the board later in the tournament so
yeah i think every little detail at the
moment is essential yeah and magnus with
the white pieces in game four
what will you put in as predictions on
uh on the prediction challenge simon i'm
i go along with what david said i think
this is probably
magnus's time in round four because the
first three rounds are they're always
going to be quite nervous because you're
getting into the flow you're trying to
get a feel for your opponent get an idea
what kind of opening not opening moves
but opening ideas they're going to play
and
now you've got the white pieces you have
a rest you play some football you're
feeling good and you really want to
start pushing and i think having white
in round four is is a big big advantage
actually to to magnus and
i think this is this would be yeah time
for him with the white pieces to push
but of course jan's playing incredibly
well and he's not going to be easy and
we saw
magnus even over maybe over pressing in
the last round so it can go wrong if he
if he tries too much so yeah very
interesting game coming up what will you
put in iranka as predictions
ah this is a difficult one actually um i
have a suspicion he will continue with
pushing his queen's pawn forward i mean
he had
quite a sharp battle in the game too
and uh definitely lots of room for uh
diverging there's also lots of room for
improvement so it works well i have to
say you know he did manage to put napoli
actually under pressure so
why not stick to the same formula you
know we saw napolita again also he stuck
to his wallet formula so maybe we're
just going to see big battles yeah in
the one opening yeah well david we did
check the the magnus nepo prediction
challenge and even you you weren't able
to
submit your predictions for the game
yesterday and you're still
very much
uh to the top of the table what was it i
think i'm 39th in the world right now
but uh there's hundreds maybe even
thousands of players competing so uh i'm
gutted i didn't put my uh my prediction
in yesterday because i would have
guessed the right opening and the right
result but uh no it's just fun to be a
part of it i definitely recommend
everyone at home to join in as well join
in the fun all right the press
conference in dubai is about to start
let's head down there just a reminder
for the photographers to stay low as we
have cameras in the back and for the
journalists after we're done with a few
preliminary questions to the players
you can go to the microphones to the
left and right of the room
do not touch the microphone and always
leave your mask on when you ask any
questions while at all of the players
jan you had your second white today
things
was there a point in the game you felt
like you might have had some chances it
seemed like it petered out pretty
quickly
well
i guess
i could roughly say that opening uh
ended up in my favor like i got some
very slight h
but it looked like it gonna be going
it's going to be let's say long term
um but then
well this uh
you know if i
moved from magnus is i mean positionally
surely quite questionable but seems like
after some pretty precise problem after
some precise moves black
can be close to equality
and well i mean d4 looks uh absolutely
natural and i mean perhaps i mean okay
if if i would realize earlier that after
d4 and exchanges after bishop six i
can't basically prevent d5
star after d5
black has some decent counter play even
in the end game i would probably
play it differently maybe i don't know
some h3 or knight e3 just
more slowly
but you know after bishop c8 d4 looks
like very natural so black has all his
pieces on
onto the last rank
uh but yes i'm half of bishop e6 it's
really it's really hard to do something
so i
spent quite some time and
you know probably the best uh the best
try
i found part of h3os
i believe knight d2 move
but even then okay uh
like for some uh
martial like okay we're playing
anti-partial but anyway martial like
extra pawn
uh against two bishops so basically
extremely close to a draw anyway so
that was it
are you feeling any frustration about
the fact that you haven't gotten going
so to speak with the white pieces yet
no i mean okay absolutely no frustration
so that's
i guess uh it was a clean game and a
very logical one and uh you know even in
the end game if i would be
you know giving attention you know a
couple of champions i could pose some
problems in this like say bishop end
game
uh but i mean okay especially once black
king center c5 and the 5f4
there is never anything for white but
well i mean uh this is
you know the current status of the
chester yes
it's hard to
uh to find some some advantage
magnus is there anything sexy you could
say about today's game
uh
well i mean there's there's a lot uh
that i i could say um
but yeah i
generally generally agree that um
i was obviously making some
some fairly ugly moves but
it seems all too uh
seems all to work out reasonably well at
least i couldn't
couldn't see any uh concrete way to uh
to pose post serious problems so i think
i think it was was
a reasonably logical game
you seem incredibly comfortable with the
black pieces so far
in this match is that the correct
sentiment
um i would say um i wouldn't say very
comfortable um i feel like i've been
trying to trying to equalize in
in both games without getting getting a
lot of a lot of chances but
it's
it's okay it's a
fairly normal procedure in in these
in these matches
uh yeah and the the trouble of the white
piece is uh you as you made it is
documented nowadays it seems very
difficult to get advantage with why even
after months of preparation what are you
going to need to do to to change the
trend
now that whatever
whatever am i going to do the trend will
remain the same
so that's uh that's not about my
preparation or magnus preparation that's
about let's say the current uh
tierra status
uh
magnus what's going to be the difference
maker you guys seem to be punching it
out right now on even terms
well it's three games then
there's uh there's a lot of a lot of
time
time to go and as you saw yesterday
could easily have been
a decisive decisive result so
um
you know yeah um
it could
obviously
for each game the most
likely result is is a draw
i mean there's just
saying otherwise would be
[Music]
would be quite uh yeah disingenuous but
there i mean any game could
could um
could explode um just
not today
one last question for me for you
the tension people see draws and they
think
it's just draws it's not so interesting
but you've been a part of these so many
years
how does attention grow with each draw
yeah
i should say obviously
as the match goes
goes along
uh with each draw you get you get a bit
more intense
um
but i would say so far yeah it's
three games and personally i've been
as i've been black and two of them i'm
fairly fairly satisfied
and
there's yeah there's a lot of a lot of
time to create something although
obviously it's not
not ever going to be easy against a very
strong opponent
all right if i may
ask the journalists you have again
microphones at both sides of the room
here um so so john i wanted to ask you
about it one moment so when he played
rookie eight were you expecting 95 which
is sort of
the main line or uh you mean ninety five
and center for kate yes was that
something you're expecting or was rick
rusz ricky eight uh
was it a surprise well in some way i
expected everything so
uh i guess after such long preparation
you
more or less try to be familiar with
most of the moves
uh but i'm sure
there are
also maybe some um worthy tries which
uh haven't been played yet but yeah okay
rookieh is one of the
pretty
logical sidelines like this whole plan
is very healthy okay bishop f8 h6 yeah
so
a little bit uh like uh there's a
variation yeah but
i mean still uh
very very nice for black
and then to magnus uh i wanted to ask
about this moment with h3
um if you if you wanted to play knight
d2 was your aim to play d5
um yeah as young as young mentioned uh
will after d5 pretty much by force gets
um get this ending with um
with an extra pawn for white which i
thought was just a dead draw
so uh
even if the bishop you know would come
to c3 and pawn on a5 where is your id to
reroute the bishop to asics possibly or
did you think no i i mean i i thought um
the bishop after
so eventually after
d5 um everything gets taken you take on
a5 rook a8 bishop c7
rook a4 um bishop goes to e5 and then c3
and
then you
you go f6 king f7 h5 um
the bishops are just
way too strong i think so you were you
would say that you're more than willing
to go into this end game or did you
consider perhaps playing another move to
keep things going and maybe perhaps some
chances
um i hadn't
i hadn't decided yet um but
i had
um
yeah i had that in reserve uh at least i
i thought so
there were there might have been other
other options but
um it didn't feel realistic that i could
that i could actually play for for
something so probably that's what i
would have done and i know on the first
day i asked you about uh
sorry we have to give all the
journalists an opportunity you can come
back on the mic if there are other
questions
thank you hi uh saranan from chessbase
ian in the official commentary uh
vishyanan was discussing about your
opening strategy
to quote him in every match people have
tried
different strategies against magnus but
so far they haven't cracked it
eon's strategy seems to be very
reasonable
his style has been classical he's
playing the royal uppers the catalon
with black
for the moment he is playing the main
line that is working for him
was this your strategy would you agree
with him and do you think it's working
for you
no but
as
she said
it seems very reasonable for him yes
i actually also hope it's reasonable but
i guess after three games you know it's
too early to discuss the strategy
[Music]
mikeline with chess.com this question is
from magnus carlson magnus this is far
from your first rodeo and i know you
have processes that have probably been
established so i'm wondering how much
are you trusting your team for in-match
opening improvements or are you still
very hands-on in the middle of a match
when looking for opening improvements
yeah it's an excellent
question
you know i don't want to
don't want to say to
um too much but
it's always um
it's always a combination
that
obviously you have a you have a good
team that you that you trust but
um
i mean at the end of the day i'm i'm
making the making the decisions
um
hi uh this is john from uh bst
from montenegro i have a question for
jan about the move h3
how happy were you at this at that point
to make that kind of a move
can you walk us through the what was
going on in your head at that point
no i think i
surely won't tell you what i was
thinking
but in general i found out that d5 is
likely inevitable and this was a way to
improve my position before d5
so maybe i could capitalize on uh that
if black would push d5 immediately but i
guess also the five workshop should work
pretty nicely uh but uh yep somehow
after h3c6 uh
it's not such a great important temp but
h3 could be useful in many lines
so i'm not getting mated on the first
rank at least
thanks
i am
from the global broadcast of chess24 the
question is primarily for magnus and
would also love to hear if ian had a
reaction
it appears that today's game was
analyzed in an online database
all the way up until move 20
two days ago
if this was somebody from your team who
forgot to make it private how would you
react
[Laughter]
i i don't think
yeah i don't think anyone any of us can
reasonably uh comment on that
well i i i can only say that normally
you try to switch up this uh online
cloud
option uh in in your chest basement you
analyze you have to make sure
no one uses
and no one uses let's say uh your
fruitful analysis
but uh i mean uh it
could probably be a coincidence as well
okay thank you
alexander significant russia one my
question is for jan and i will ask
all right you guys we got an answer to
our question kind of what you read out
of that david yeah i mean first of all
it's nice to see them both smiling
i mean you could see magnus's mind
racing right he was like oh my god who
was it
but yeah of course they can't reveal
anything in public about who it might
have been or what happened but either
way it seems it was a bit of a mishap
and someone made a bit of a blunder
there
in his team or john's team
oh i have a feeling it might oh no
comment
yeah i think so yeah the way his his
eyes just kind of went
and then he laughed and it's like oh so
do you think we actually caught it that
there has been a mishap
i think so yeah i think i think just the
reaction there that was the most i've
seen him laugh yeah smile with a
question so it's a very good question
but yeah well daniel vancouver for
finding that information
yeah
i think we should all become detectives
right right well and you said it
you know definitely modern chess we can
actually
follow what's been analyzed on
an online database and see the game
unfold as well is it a shift for chess
what we're seeing it's a shift i mean it
takes a lot of hard work a lot of time a
lot of energy to go and delve into the
deep kind of dark
corners of all these different openings
but at the same time it does make it
more exciting for us watching the games
to just try and figure out what's going
through the players minds what the teams
are working on what the coaches are
working on and it just adds a new
dimension and for that i'm quite
appreciative yep all right well it did
end in the draw this uh third game in
dubai tomorrow's gonna be a rest day
let's take a look at the schedule for
the chess 24 global broadcast
on uh
tuesday game four will
be the next game magnus carlson will
have the white pieces and we start every
show at
one o'clock pm cet that's four o'clock
in dubai that's gonna be seven in the
morning in new york tuesday is going to
be in the next game game 5 will be on
wednesday and then another rest day on
thursday before the next games on friday
saturday and
sunday tomorrow is going to be a rest
day how are you going to enjoy that
simon
in oslo by yeah by resting i guess yeah
um i'll probably have a it's a lovely
city i'll probably have a little walk
down the harbour and uh i hear there's a
ski run so i might um
go to the top of that and run down that
who knows um just see a bit of the
scenery i think and just take it easy so
yeah and uh personally i can't wait for
game four on tuesday but also because
it's the birthday day it's magnus
carlson's birthday and
someone else's birthday as well
so uh don't miss it it's gonna be a day
of celebration a day of a lot of
exciting chess definitely we're going to
celebrate both ginger gm simon williams
here in the studio and world champion
magnus carlson turning 31 years old on
awesome
turning 31 yeah on day four in the world
championship match it's been an
interesting day not too long day maybe
game four will be a longer one uh it's
been nice having you joining us from
around the world thanks for watching
everyone and hopefully we'll see you on
tuesday bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you